فجاءنا عرض «جاهز»
وكان في أيدينا عروض ثانية
كان عندنا عروض ثانية أعلى من عرض «جاهز»
كم كانت الصفقات؟ تقدر تشاركها وللا؟
والله هذه من المعلومات اللي ما نقدر نشاركها
لأن ما فصحوا هم
طيب، أنا أقول أرقام واغمز
اكتشفنا أن يتصلوا عليهم
وقّع معي حصري، وراح أعطيك 200 ألف ريال
إيه، فكانوا يعطون عروض خرافية
قال لي: عبدالرحمن اهرب
قال: هؤلاء عندهم ميزانية ضخمة
عندهم 15 مليون يصرفونها في التسويق
أنا بالنسبة لي 15 مليون رقم مرعب
والله ما أنساها، قال: ترى راح يأكلون الأخضر واليابس
انحش، وقفّل، وللا شوف لك صرفة
أنا كنت مصمم أني أدخل موسم الرياض
وأعرف المنافسة فيه صعبة جدًّا
وأعرف أنهم راح يطلبون مبلغ عالي
ممكن أنا ما أقدر على المبلغ هذا
أيش سويت؟
قلت: ما لي إلا أكلم معالي المستشار، تركي آل الشيخ
دورنا، إلى أن جبت رقمه
أرسلت له رسالة طويلة
احنا شباب سعودي، أعطيته الكليشة
واحنا سوينا مع موسم الرياض، واحنا نبغى دعمكم
قلت: راح أرسل، إذا رد...
أيش أسوأ شيء ممكن يصير؟ ما يرد أو ممكن يعطيني بلوك
يالله حيهم، ضيفنا اليوم عبدالرحمن الشبانات
مؤسس تطبيق «ذا شفز»
اللي أتوقع حتى اللي ما يعرفهم صار يعرفهم مؤخرًا
بعد محاولة استحواذ «جاهز» عليهم
راح أسولف مع ضيفنا أولًا عن قصة التطبيق
بما أن قليل اللي يعرفون سالفته
وما تكلم عن عبدالرحمن كثير سابقًا
راح نتكلم عن كيف بدأ كتطبيق يخدم الأسر المنتجة؟
إلى ما وصل لشكله الحالي
وأيش يميزهم اليوم عن باقي تطبيقات التوصيل؟
بما أن في تطبيقات توصيل كثيرة
سنغطي أيضًا تفاصيل رعايتهم لموسم الرياض لعدة مواسم
وتجربتهم مع رعاية نادي الشباب
والشيء اللي كثير راح يسمعون الحلقة عشانه
أيش اللي خلى شركتين متنافستين في السوق تفشل في الاستحواذ عليهم؟
اللي هم «ديليفري هيرو» و«جاهز»
ولا، مو عشان انخفضت قيمة سهم «جاهز» والسالفة المتداولة هذه
حوار ممتع في حلقة مليانة معلومات يشاركها الضيف لأول مرة
أترككم معها
حياك الله أبو راكان
الله يحييك ويبقيك، يا مرحبا
سعيد جدًّا أن كسبناك أخيرًا في البرنامج
وأنا أسعد، شكرًا، تحملكم مشقة التواصل، تعبناكم معنا، لكن..
كم؟ سنتين؟
تقريبًا
والله لو أبي أستحوذ عليك كان خلصت، مو طبيعي
أسرع
لا، بس شرفتنا اليوم وآنستنا، ومتحمس جدًّا صراحة
غير المواضيع اللي أكيد راح نتكلم عنها
اللي تخص استحواذات «ديليفري هيرو» و«جاهز»
ودي قبلها وقبل تفاصيل كثيرة ثانية ندخلها عن «ذا شفز»
نتكلم عن قصة «ذا شفز» بشكل عام
ما أتوقع أنكم تكلمتوا عنها كثير، وهذا الشيء تفاجأت فيه
شركات كثير ثانية، نشوف كيف تأسست، وأيش تفاصيلها؟
في مقالات وفي تغريدات وفي برامج، وفي سوالف بزنس
أنتم..غامض الموضوع شوي
قليل الظهور، احنا طلعنا في بعض المبادرات «منشآت» تحديدًا
لكن بشكل عام، لا
ما في شيء تسجل
كثير من الناس يجهل قصة «ذا شفز»
عاد تفاجأت أنا بمعلومة اللي...
راح تقول لنا السالفة كاملة، بس كانت تخص البداية
أنك استقلت، وتفرغت في شهر العسل
لا، هذه الله يسلمك «عبدالرحمن المرشد» شريكي
مو أنت؟
إيه
«عبدالرحمن» شكله قال: أيش أسوأ وقت أختاره؟
لا، أنا اللي للأسف
شلون؟
كنت أدق عليه في شهر العسل
أقول له: يا «عبدالرحمن» أنا مضغوط
في ذلك الوقت ما في إلا أنا وهو نشتغل في 2016
هذا متى؟ بداية الـ...
لو أرجع، احنا بدأنا فعليًّا الفكرة في 2016، فكانت فكرة
وكنا نشوف أن السوق يحتاج منصة تجمع تجار الأكل المنزلي
قبل اسمنا ما كان «ذا شفز»
كان اسمنا «شغل بيت»
فوقتها كنا نعتقد أن الفكرة هذه جبارة وعظيمة
اللي هو احنا اللي راح نخلي الناس تأكل من أكل منازل
ما تأكل من المطاعم
كان هدفنا نقضي على سوق المطاعم
تمام
وكنا نعتقد أن الفكرة جميلة
تتذكر الشعور اللي يجيك أيام عيد الفطر؟
تأكلون بالحارة مع بعض
فقلنا خلنا نأسس منصة تجمع جميع رواد الطهي المنزلي
تحت مظلة وحدة، وسميناها «شغل بيت»
بنفس نظام تطبيقات التوصيل؟
إي، وقتها تعرف انتشر مصطلح الاقتصاد التشاركي
اللي بدأت فيه «أوبر» و«كريم»
أن أنت تستغل الموارد اللي عند الناس
تقدمها للمستفيدين، وتكون حلقة الوصل بينهم
فاحنا طلعنا الفكرة هذه، وكنا نعتقد أن المشكلة اللي نسعى إلى حلها
أن المتاجر المنزلية عددهم كثير جدًّا
ومبعثرين صعب توصل لهم
فإذا أنت تبي تجرب أكل منزلي
غالبًا يجيك عن طريق واحد قال لك أو أعطاك توصية
قال لك: هذه العلامة التجارية أو هذا المطعم
أو الطباخ المنزلي شغله كويس
بس تبي تجرب غيره؟ ما تقدر، ما في منصة تجمعهم
يلا تدور في إنستقرام
في إنستقرام وحوسة
فكنا نعتقد أن هذه هي المشكلة الوحيدة
اللي لو حليناها، راح نكسر السوق
فأيش حلها؟ تسوي منصة تجمعهم كلهم
فبدأنا بداية 2016 نشتغل على جمع البيانات
أنا و«عبدالرحمن المرشد»
«عبدالرحمن» كان ماسك المبيعات، جبته أنا لأنه...
في المبيعات
إيه، مميز هو أنه يقدر يقنع، ويقدر يسولف
بيّاع
بيّاع، يحب يسولف، لا أنا ما أحب
وكانت أغلب رحلاتنا، المبيعات أن نروح نزور الأسر نفسهم
نقلط عندهم في البيت أو في المجلس أو في الملحق
نحاول نقنعهم ونوريهم صور التطبيق
فجلسنا الفترة الأولى تقريبًا
مين الأسر اللي اخترتوها؟ رحتوا بشكل عشوائي؟
كنا نبحث في إنستقرام، جمّعنا تقريبًا 500 علامة تجارية
ما شاء الله
بذلنا مجهود، فجمعنا كل شخص عنده خبرة
وعنده القدرة أن يطلع طلبات من بيته
حلو
فسوّينا المنتج
وقررتوا تبدأون مع مين؟ الأشهر وللا؟
إيه، الأشهر وقتها، بس فتحناها كلها
كانت المنصة متجر
اللي يبي يسجل يسجل
اللي يبي يسجل يسجل في البداية
فكنت تحمّل التطبيق، أول ما تدخل التطبيق
تلقى، أنت عميل، وللا أنت طاهي؟ فتسجل كطاهي
فجلسنا خمسة شهور تقريبًا
بنينا التطبيق، وشغلنا التطبيق، تحمسنا
قلنا: الحين تجينا الطلبات، ما جاءت طلبات
سوّقنا وندفع للمؤثرين اعلنوا للمنصة
ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي، ما جاءت طلبات
يالله تجيك يمكن في الأسبوع يجيك طلب واحد
وإذا جاءك الطلب هذا تقعد أنت تشتغل عليه يوم كامل
لأنه يطلب، من البداية احنا مشتغلين على خدمة الجدولة
تقدر تطلب قبل وقت التوصيل بفترة معينة
وكنا احنا ما نقوم بدور التوصيل
احنا فقط نأخذ الطلب، ونعطيه للمتجر المنزلي
وهو خلاص يتولى الطلب
وتأخذون نسبة؟
ما كنا نأخذ نسبة، نأخذ مبلغ بسيط
عادةً كنا نأخذ تقريبًا ريالين وشوي
لدرجة كنا نروح نجلس مع بعض الأسر
يقول: لا، نقّص وخفض
أقول: يلا ريالين وربع
فحتى اقتصاديًّا ما كنا دارسين
الريالين هذه ما راح تعيّشك
أصلًا السوق نفسه سوق الأسر المنتجة سوق صغير جدًّا
فبدأنا نشتغل، وبدأت الطلبات تجي، وكانت متعبة
لأن كل طلب يجيك لازم تروح تدق على الطباخة أم فلان
جهزي الطلب، جاءك طلب، واحنا اللي نقبله
بعدين العميل يدق علينا أيش صار على الطلب؟ الطلب طلع؟
ما ندري، المندوب مو تبعنا
وما فيه ربط، ولا فيه تتبع
أتصور برضو الأسر المنتجة في صعوبة في أنك أصلًا تعتمد عليهم
مو الكل
أكيد في نسبة منهم ممتازين جدًّا
بس في ناس ثانيين ماخذينها هواية
بالضبط، فتعبنا كانت رحلة متعبة
فعودةً على سؤالك، استقلت أنا في شهر يوليو تقريبًا 2016
استقلت، خطوة تعتبر جريئة وغير مدروسة
لأن التطبيق لسّه ما يدخّل فلوس
ووضعه المستقبلي ما هو واضح
أيش خلاك تستقيل إذا ما في طلبات؟
كان عندي أنا شغف قبل أني أتفرغ لشيء أنا أشتغل فيه
مو ذابحنا إلا الشغف هذا
إيه، ووقتها أيضًا في 2016
تذكر 2016 الرؤية أُطلِقت في أبريل
الاقتصاد السعودي كان في مرحلة صعبة
النفط نزل أقل من ثلاثين دولار
فكان الوضع ما هو أفضل وضع أنك تبدأ عمل تجاري
فهو مو شغف، هو في شيء ثاني؟
أنا أبغى أسوي شيء، مع أن وظيفتي كانت ممتازة
راتبي وقتها كان تقريبًا 20 ألف
وكنت مع «المركز الوطني للأمن الإلكتروني»
كان مركز جديد، وممسكينّي إدارة لحالي
وعندي صلاحيات وفي تمكين
طيب «شغل بيت» ما كان فيه طلبات واجد
وعندك وظيفة زينة، اصبر على الأقل، أيش اللي خلاك...؟
أنا كنت مؤمن بمقولة «صاحب البالين كذاب»
وكنت نوعًا ما ببعض الأحيان أنا أشتغل في وقت عملي
لصالح مشروعي الخاص، وكان في تعارض مصالح
فقررت أني أستقيل
خصوصًا أن أنا سأستقيل لشيء تقني فلو خرب أو ما مشى وفشل
أبي أرجع أقول: أنا استفدت خبرة تقنية في مجال معين
وأكمل في سوق العمل
وزائد أن وقتها ما كان عندي التزامات أسرية
ما كنت متزوج، وما كان عندي قروض
كنت شباب عادي أقدر أعيش بدون راتب
فاستخرنا، واستقلنا
بدأت أشتغل لحالي أنا و«عبدالرحمن»
«عبدالرحمن» تزوج، وراح شهر العسل
يوم راح شهر العسل زاد الضغط علي
قبلها قلت لك كنا منصة فقط «شغل بيت»
اكتشفنا أن النموذج هذا ما ينجح
لازم أنت تملك التجربة كاملة
لازم أنت تقدم خدمة أنه يسجل ويبحث ويختار ويطلب ويدفع
ويتتبع الطلب ويقيّم، إلى آخره، تجربة كاملة
فقلنا: عندك 500 متجر، بعضهم مثلما قلت يشتغل هواة
وبعضهم لا، احترافيين، عنده مطبخ منزلي مجهَّز
وجايب عاملات أو عاملين منزليين
فاختصرنا القائمة من 500 تاجر منزلي أو طباخ أو طاهي منزلي
إلى خمسين
وغيّرنا الاسم إلى «ذا شفز»
فمصطلح «ذا شفز» أنهم هم النخبة في السوق
فقلنا: كذا الحين حلينا المشكلة، كذا العميل يقدر يطلب
ويتتبع الطلب، ويجيه طلبه
فكنا فكرتنا أننا ما نبغى منصة فقط تستقبل طلبات
وترميه للأسر المنتجة
لا، احنا نبغى نمسك التجربة كاملة
فغيرنا إلى «ذا شفز» اختصرنا إلى خمسين تاجر وتاجرة
بس ما زلتوا أسر منتجة؟
ما زلنا أسر منتجة
بدأت شوي الأمور تتحسن، بدأ يجينا طلب في اليوم
يوم إي، ويوم لا
فاستقلت أنا عاد، وبعدين «المرشد» راح شهر العسل
وزاد الضغط علي، جالس لحالي
فدقيت عليه، وقلت: يا أخي ما ينفع أنت في شهر العسل، وأنا أشتغل
قال: ليش؟ قلت: لازم تستقيل
يا ابن الحلال أنا توني متزوج
أنت تقول: استقلنا؟
أنا استقلت لحالي
هو ما استقال؟
قلت: لازم تستقيل
قال: اصبر خلني ارجع من شهر العسل
قلت: خلاص، إذا رجعت، إن شاء الله، من شهر العسل
جهز أمورك تراك راح تستقيل
وأقنعته أن احنا لازم نأخذ التجربة هذه، ونغامر ونكافح
ما في ثمرة إلا بكفاح
والرجل صدّق بس، الحمد لله، عدت على خير
فأنت تشوف أنها متهورة الحركة مرة؟
فعلًا متهورة
ما أبي واحد يأخذها فكرة أنه إلهام وللا؟
لا، أنا عكسها تمامًا
اللي سويته أنت جدًّا متهور
إي عكسها تمامًا، عشان تستقيل، وتترك مصدر دخل ثابت
لازم يكون عندك شيء نوعًا ما واضح المعالم
بدأ يصير عندي دخل، وبدأت أحصّل استثمار
فهو استقال في نهاية السنة تقريبًا
وغيّرنا إلى المنصة الجديدة
وأيضًا نهاية السنة، سبحان الله، قدرنا أن نجيب أول استثمار ملائكي
كنت أرسل، سوينا رسوم متحركة
الرسوم المتحركة أتذكر أوّل صوت يطلع
يقول: ملّيت من أكل المطاعم؟ اطلب من «ذا شفز»
فأرسلته لواحد من الشباب، يمكن تعرفه «عبدالله الدوسري»
إيه، معروف، استضفناه في البرنامج
فشافها، قال: أيش تسوي أنت؟
قلت له: والله احنا عندنا منصة أسر منتجة
واحنا نعتقد هذا السوق كبير، وهدفنا تغيير سلوك العميل
ما يطلب من المطاعم، ويطلب من أكل البيت
فقال: أيش تحتاجون؟ قلنا: احنا نحتاج استثمار
فدخل معنا، الله يجزاه خير، ساعدنا
باللي يسمونه مساهمة عينية
قال: أبي أحط معكم مبلغ، بس ما راح أعطيكم نقدًا
راح أعطيكم مقابله خدمات
فكان عنده شركة تطوير ساعدتنا، وخدمات إدارية، وإلى آخره
اللي هي «تي تو»
إيه
اللي قابلناه في البرنامج
الشركة الشقيقة اللي عندهم في الأردن «نيكست تو»
يوفرون خدمات التطوير
بس قبل هذه، اللي سمعته أنكم أول جولة استثمارية فتحتوها ما أحد جاء
لا، راح أعلمك أنا الحين
هذه بعدها؟
إيه، فهو الرجل جاء شرانا فعليًّا، ما جاء شرى أرقام
ما شاف أرقام، الأرقام سيئة جدًّا
هو شاف اثنين متحمسين، عنده إيمان وقتها
وعنده نظرة أن هؤلاء ممكن ينجحون
فقال: أنا راح ألتزم معكم
وقتها ما كان عندنا رواتب
«عبدالرحمن» توه مستقيل ومتزوج، وضعه صعب
فحددنا لنا رواتب تقريبًا بدأنا بـ 5000 لفترة معينة كل واحد له 5000
بعدين كمّلنا إلى 2017
أنتم ما كنتوا تتقاسمون رواتبكم قبل أو شيء زي كذا؟
إيه، هي فعليًّا كانت 10 آلاف، هو اتفقنا معه على 10 آلاف
5000 آلاف لـ 5000
مع «عبدالرحمن»؟
أنا 5 آلاف لي و5 آلاف لـ«عبدالرحمن المرشد»
بس 10 آلاف من اللي...؟
10 آلاف من «الدوسري» جزء من الاستثمار اللي حطه
فقال: أبي أعطيكم رواتب، وأتكفل ببعض الخدمات الإدارية
ما كان في إلا أنت و«عبدالرحمن» بس؟
وقتها ما في إلا أنا و«عبدالرحمن»
من اللي كان مسوي لكم المنصة قبل والأمور هذه؟
هذه أنا رحت جبت شركة في الهند، بحثت
بحكم أن خلفيتي تقنية، تخرجت من هندسة حاسب
فأقدر أدير المنتجات التقنية وقتها
فجبت لي لشركة ما كلفتنا شيء تقريبًا
رأس مال المشروع في البداية ما تجاوز الـ 100 ألف
فجبنا الشركة الهندية هذه سوّت لنا التطبيق
وبعد فترة كبّينا الكود، وجبنا شركة ثانية، وسوّينا نفس الشغلة
كبّينا الشغل، وبدأنا من جديد
فهي رحلة مستمرة في التطوير
في 2017 إذا راح نمشي بالتسلسل الزمني
خلاص استقر الموضوع أن احنا عندنا منصة «ذا شفز»
اللي تجمع لك أمهر الطهات المنزليين
فرحنا استأجرنا فندق، قاعة وجمعنا جميع الأسر المنتجة
وعيشناهم الجو، وأن احنا طموحنا عالي، وسوقنا راح يكبر معكم
أيش ودكم نسوي؟ إلى آخره
وكنا نعتقد أن هذا السوق فعلًا راح يكبر
في 2017 بداية أول شهر إلى تقريبًا منتصف السنة
ما زالت معدل الطلبات قليل جدًّا
اثنين وعشرين طلب في الشهر كحد أقصى
تخيل أنا مستقيل وهو مستقيل
جالسين مقابلين وجوه بعض، وما في طلبات
وإذا جاء طلب، مبسوط وأكلمه
بس ما هي هذه الفرصة اللي أنت استقلت علشانها
مو هذه الفرصة اللي أنت بغيت تبني عليها مستقبلك
فجاء أتذكر في أغسطس 2017
دقيت على «عبدالرحمن»
قلت: راح أمرك، عندهم حديقة حول بيتهم
دائمًا نمشي فيها، ونطلع أفكار
فهو ما كان يدري أيش السالفة
فقلت: «عبدالرحمن» وضعنا غلط
أنا وإياك تحمسنا، وتركنا وظائفنا، وسوينا شيء غلط
السوق هذا ما راح ينجح، السوق قليل، ومعاييره صعبة
مثلا أنا أتذكر وقتها ناس يبغون يدعموني يدقون علي
يقولون: نبي نطلب، أنا عندي مناسبة أبي أطلب من تطبيقك
أيش تنصحنا؟
ما كنت أقدر أجاوب، ما كنت أقدر أنصحه بتاجر منزلي
لأن وقتها، كان أغلب اللي شغالين معنا
ما عندهم مستوى ثابت في الأكل
قصدك أنت الوجبة اليوم غير عن وجبة بكرة؟
إي، شوف في قطاع الأكل لازم يكون عندك مستوى ثابت
أكلك سيء؟ كمل أنت سيء، راح تلقى ناس يحبون أكلك
فتلقى الناس يحبون بعض...
فعودنا على شيء واحد، لا تغير
إيه، لا تغير، فهذه المشكلة واجهتنا، حاولنا نحل المشكلة
قلنا لبعضهم: تعال، أنتِ علامتك التجارية «أم فهد»
ما ينفع علامة تجارية اسمها «أم فهد»
سوّينا اسم جديد، وحطينا لها شعار
وحطينا لها صحون جديدة، وتغليف
ما مشى الموضوع
يجيها طلبات، والله أنا مسافرة
وللا مثلًا عندي عزيمة، وللا نحن مسافرين، وللا أبونا مرض
فشفنا القطاع هذا ما راح ينجح
فدقيت على «عبدالرحمن»
قلت له: «عبدالرحمن» احنا جالسين نسوي شيء غلط
عفوًا يا نوقف الشركة، ونرجع وظائفنا، وللا نغيّر التوجه تمامًا
قال: صعب، فكان في شعور صعب مرير أنك ترجع لوظيفتك
كأنه شعور الاعتراف بالهزيمة
بعدما أنت كنت طالع، لأن حتى أتذكر لما طلعت
كان مدير المركز يقول لي: يا ولدي تراك طالع في وقت غلط
اصبر، واشتغل معنا، أخذ إجازة بدون راتب
قلت: لا، أنا أبي أطلع، لازم أشتغل الحين هذه فرصتي الذهبية
فاكتشفنا أن لا، الوضع غلط
فجاء اليوم اللي بعده، قلنا خلنا ندرس السوق
أيش الأشياء اللي ممكن نسويها؟
وقتها السوق في 2017 كان فيه طلبات
كان فيه «فودباندا» إذا تذكره
و«هنقرستيشن» و«وصّل» و«جاهز» توّه طالع
بس كان فيه عمالقة اللي هم طلبات و«فودباندا» و«هنقرستيشن»
كلهم يتشابهون
إي، فدرسنا السوق، قلنا: أيش ممكن نسوي؟
ممكن نسوي شيء في التجارة الإلكترونية، ننافس «سوق دوت كوم»
التجارة الإلكترونية
إيه، التجارة الإلكترونية العامة
ممكن نسوي توصيل من المطاعم الفارهة
حطيناها كذا أفكار
ممكن نسوي توصيل من متاجر الحلويات والكيك، وإلى آخره
ممكن نسوي توصيل لمعدات الطبخ، وإلى آخره
ممكن نسوي توصيل من مطاعم الأكل السريع
اللي زي طلبات، وإلى آخره
بعدين سوينا دراسة التحليل الرباعي
اللي هي تدرس نقاط القوة والضعف والفرص والمخاطر
كل واحدة جلسنا نحللها
فاكتشفنا أن الأكل السريع وقتها كان نوعًا ما متشعّب
وما نقدر ندخل على سوق شركات مليارية تدعمهم
وكل شركة أكبر من الثانية، واحنا شباب تونا مستقيلين
ورواتبنا 5 آلاف، وما عندنا فلوس حتى
وعلامات تجارية كبيرة هم عندهم اليد العليا في التفاوض
ويضغطون عليك أكثر
فقلنا: لا، شطّب على الأكل السريع
طيب الأكل الفاره والمطاعم...
في السوق احنا نقسمه إلى المطاعم الفاخرة
وعندنا المطاعم العادية
ومطاعم الوجبات السريعة اللي هم يسمونه سريعة التحضير
هذا وجبات سريعة
سريعة مرة
اللي فوقه عادي يعني أكل برقر بس عنده جلسات ومرتب
وثم عاد المطاعم الفارهة اللي أكثر من صنف في الأكل
تطلع والفاتورة 500 ريال
فقلنا: نبغى نركز على هؤلاء
قبل لا نتخذ القرار، سوينا شيء جميل
قبلها كنا نقرأ أن أنت لازم تختبر السوق
قبلما تسوي أي تغير أو تحور
لازم تختبر السوق، وتسأل العملاء
لأنهم في النهاية هم اللي لهم اليد العليا
ما هو برأيي أو رأيك
فأذكر لما حطينا المطاعم الفارهة
كنت أقول: من العميل المنطقي اللي... منطقي كلمة جميلة
اللي راح يطلب من مطعم زي مثلًا «نوزومي» توصيل؟
أنت تبي تروح له لازم...
تعيش التجربة
لازم تعيش التجربة، وتصور وتعلّم الناس اللي حولك
أنك رحت وصرت من الطبقة...
أصلًا جزء من اللي يبرر لك قيمة الفاتورة أنك رحت، وعشت الجو
فعلًا، إيه، وتلقاك أسبوع كامل تسولف فيها
أقيس على مستواي، وطبقتي اللي كنت أعيش فيها
وهذا الشيء غلط
فقلنا: حسنًا، كنت أقرأ في أحد الكتب
أن أنت لازم تطلع من المكتب، وتسأل العملاء
فقلنا خلنا نتواصل مع العملاء
فمسكنا قاعدة البيانات اللي عندنا
تواصلنا تقريبًا مع 1600 عميل
نفس اللي كانوا يطلبون من الأسر المنتجة؟
نفس اللي كانوا، جزء كانوا يطلبون
وجزء كانوا يسجلون فقط، ما طلبوا
فـ1600 عميل اتصلت عليهم أنا و«عبدالرحمن المرشد»
تليفون ندق عليه، ألو معك عبدالرحمن الشبانات
المدير العام لتطبيق «ذا شفز»
أقدر أخذ من وقتك خمس دقائق؟ عندنا بعض الأسئلة
أي واحد تقول له: خمس دقائق، يقول لك: لا
فهذه من الأشياء اللي تعلمناها إذا تبي تسوي استبيان
اسأل على طول، لا تقول: هذا الوقت مناسب؟
دائمًا الوقت غير مناسب
فكنا نسألهم، نقول: لو لبستك قبعة المدير العام
وأعطيتك جميع الصلاحيات أنك تطور في التطبيق
أيش الأشياء اللي راح تسويها؟ وأيش الأشياء اللي راح تشيلها؟
فكنا نسمع منهم، ثم نسألهم عن القطاعات اللي كنا نفكر فيها
الوجبات السريعة
فكنا نقول: الأكل الفاره؟ فكانوا يقولون: نعم، احنا نغبى
الكيك؟ نعم، احنا نبغى
فاكتشفنا أن أغلب العملاء اللي كانوا عندنا
متقبلين فكرة أنه يطلب من المطاعم الفارهة
على عكس نظرتنا أن لا، الفكرة ما تجي
فاحنا تقريبًا، تخيل أن من بداية 2017 إلى شهر سبتمبر
سوينا بتسعة شهور بس 300 طلب
قدرنا نوقع مع أول علامة تجارية
وهذه من الاستراتيجيات اللي فادتنا في التوقيع مع العلامات التجارية
أن احنا ركزنا على أقوى علامة تجارية نوعًا ما وقتها
عشان ما أحد يزعل
قبلما ندخل على أقوى علامة تجارية
ما تكلمنا عن الجولة الاستثمارية اللي افتتحتوها
لسه
لسه هذه بعد؟
إيه، احنا اللي سويناه أول شيء، استثمار ملائكي
شخص جاء قال: أبي أدعمكم
اللي هو بس «عبدالله الدوسري»؟
إيه، أبي أدعمكم، أنتم ناس مهبّل
بس أعتقد أنكم ماشيين نوعًا ما، أبي أدعمكم
فنرجع لنقطة بس أنكم أول مطعم وقعتم مع مين؟
أول علامة تجارية
احنا قلنا عندنا تطبيقنا مليان أسر منتجة
نبي نوقع، أفضل مطعم في رياض وقتها
من المطاعم الفخمة
إيه، نظرتي شخصية كنا نشوف أن «نوزومي» وقتها في 2017
اللي ما يعرف «نوزومي» أيش يبيع المطعم؟
«نوزومي» يبيع أكل آسوي، وقتها كان شائع
فقلنا خلنا نركز عليه، ليش؟
إذا جبناه احنا نقدر نروح نجيب المنافسين
ونقول: معنا فلان، تعال ادخل معنا
فجلسنا تقريبًا ثلاثة شهور نحاول نقنعهم
حتى أتذكر بداية الاجتماعات كان مدير بريطاني
يطق يده على الطاولة، ويقول: مستحيل أوقع معكم
احنا تجربة، واحنا معتمدين العميل يدخل عندنا
مستحيل نسوي توصيل
فرحنا لعلامات تجارية ثانية في الكيك، على سبيل المثال «ليلو»
شغّال في البحرين
وفي البحرين في تطبيقات سابقتنا زي طلبات، وإلى آخره
و«أوبر إيتس» ما قدروا يوقعون معه
هو رافض فكرة أن أنا أشتغل مع وجبات سريعة
ومشكلتهم أنهم ما يبون ينحطون مع علامات تجارية
ما أبي أقول رخيصة، بس خلنا نقول ما هي فخمة
إيه، لأن تبيّن حساسية السعر
أنا أبي أطلب، أفتح تطبيق
ألقى مثلًا «حمص أبو زكي» مثلًا بخمسة ريال
بعدين «نوزومي»
بعدين مثلًا علامة تجارية يبيع حمص بخمسة وعشرين ريال
لا، هذا يلعب علي، فهذا تجربته مختلفة
برضو النظرة للعلامة التجارية أنه تقلل من قيمتها
إيه، مثلًا أصحاب العلامات التجارية المميزة
تلقاه ما يفتح مثلًا في الدور الأخير للمجمعات مع صفة المطاعم
تلقاه لازم يأخذ له عمارة أو شارع مميزين علشان يفتح فيه
فكانوا مركزين أن ما يدخلون تمامًا
ولا أحد قدر أن يتواصل معهم
فاحنا قلنا شفنا هذه فرصة لنا
وجلسنا فترة طويلة مع «نوزومي» يمكن ثلاثة شهور
إلى أن وقع
أيش اللي أقنعهم؟
تتابع مسلسل «المكتب»؟
إي
تعرف «مايكل»؟
إيه، مديرهم الخبل
«مايكل» أتذكر شفت له حلقة مميزة
راح عند شركة كبيرة، وهم يبيعون منتجات ورق
الشركة الكبيرة هذه قالت: أنتم مورّد بسيط على قد حاله
فيه المنافس الثاني أكبر وأفضل منكم
ليش أروح معكم؟
قال له «مايكل».... هذه أستشهد فيها دائمًا
أنه قال «احنا صغار بس احنا نقدر نعطيك الانتباه تبعنا كامل»
انتباهنا كامل
انتباهنا كامل لك، الكبير ما يقدر
أنت بالنسبة لنا أهم عميل، رضاك عندنا الأولوية العالية
تدخل مع التطبيقات الثانية أو المنافسين الكبار، راح تضيع بينهم
فكنا نستخدم نفس الاستراتيجية
الحين اللي ما قد تابع «المكتب» يحسب «مايكل» شخص ملهم جدًّا
هو ملهم بالنسبة لي
أنا تابعته ثلاث مرات المسلسل
فجلسنا معهم، واقتنعوا
فكنا حتى أتذكر...
بس أنك قلت لهم: احنا راح نركز عليكم
إيه، فأتذكر حتى سوينا عرض تقديمي
وفتح التطبيق، قال: أيش هذا؟ أم فلانة وأم فلان وما أدري
صدق أنت حاطهم مع الأسر المنتجة
إيه، قال: شلون تبي تدخلني معهم؟
فسبحان الله، الله ألهمني الجواب أن لا، هؤلاء مرحلة صفر
حذف يا مدير
لا، قلت له: هؤلاء مرحلة صفر، هؤلاء جالسين نطبق عليهم
عشان ما يزعلون بعد مننا
احنا ما نقدر نطبق عليكم
لازم نجيب ناس نطبق عليهم، لأنكم أنتم حساسين
فأنتم مرحلة رقم واحد، وهم مرحلة صفر
فأول ما نبدأ معكم نوقفهم
تقول لي: ما تعرف تبيع بعد
تابعت «المكتب»
فمشت، الحمد لله، وقعوا معنا
آخر ثلاثة شهور في 2017
بس أيش سويتوا في الأسر المنتجة؟
كملنا معهم، وبدأنا نصفيهم شوي
بدأنا نشتغل على المطاعم الفارهة
فلاحظ صار في تغير جذري بسرعة
حسينا أننا فعلًا نسوي شيء صح
في 2017 أول تسع شهور تقريبًا 300 طلب
بعنا بـ90 ألف، يعني معدل 10 آلاف ريال لكل شهر
في آخر ثلاث شهور بعنا بـ400 ألف ريال
ما شاء الله
هذه اللي سواها لكم «نوزومي» المفروض؟
«نوزومي» واللي جاء معه
واللي جاؤوا الثانيين
«طوكيو» والعلامات التجارية الثانية
أتصور الباقين أسهل إذا قلت لهم: معي «نوزومي»
إيه، فـ«طوكيو» رحنا لهم
قلنا مثلًا... هم أصدقائي، وداعمين لنا
دعمونا من البداية، وخشوا معنا
العلامات التجارية الثانية في الحالة نفس الحكاية
حتى أتذكر، لما كنا نوقع مع «ليلو»
كان شارط علي في العقد أني ما أروح مطاعم وجبات سريعة
لهذه الدرجة؟
إيه، أن إذا رحت مطاعم وجبات سريعة أبي أطلع من التطبيق
فكنت أقول: نعم، أنا معك
لأن هذا أصلًا هذا تمركزي، وهذه استراتيجيتي أني أركز فقط في النخبة
فكان في طلب فعليًّا في السوق سواءً من ناحية العملاء
أو من ناحية المطاعم
ما قدروا يغطونه في التطبيقات الثانية
بالضبط
فأنت ما قلت أبي أسوي تطبيق توصيل زي أي أحد
أنا أبي أأخذ لي تموضع بفي مكان ما أحد يخدمه حاليًّا
بالضبط، فادنا،، الحمد لله، ليش؟
لأن صار سعر التذكرة وسعر الطلب، متوسط الطلب عالي جدًّا
فصرنا نوعًا ما زي الحصري معهم بس ماني حصري في العقود
فصار الشخص اللي يبغى يطلب من المطاعم الراقية هذه
يجي في باله «ذا شفز»
كم تقريبًا كان متوسط....؟
الطلبات؟
لأن اللي أعرفه أن حقين الوجبات السريعة
الظاهر خمسين أو ستين ريال
لا، احنا وقتها كنا نوصل إلى 300 ريال متوسط الطلب
الطلبات عندنا تتجاوز الـ 5 أو 6 آلاف ريال
فطلب واحد يساوي ستة طلبات من المنافسين
الطلب الواحد أحتاج له مندوب واحد
هو يحتاج ستة مناديب
أنا أحتاج عدد موظفين أقل في التشغيل لإدارة الطلبات
هو يحتاج أكثر، وإلى آخره
أنا عندي وقت أني أقدر أبدع، وأبتكر خدمات إضافية
فعشان كذا احنا في 2017 طلعنا خدمة الاستلام
تقدر أنت تطلب وتستلم، بس وقفناها على طول
اكتشفنا فيها تلاعب، لأن ما كان عندنا...
تقدر برضو تقدم خدمة مخصصة
أنا خابر فيه مطاعم فخمة كانوا يبون من تطبيقات التوصيل
أن يرسلوا لهم مناديب لابسين لبس مثلًا معين
هذا الشيء ما يقدرون عليه التطبيقات العادية
هل قد سويتوها؟
إيه نعم، كنا حريصين جدًّا على المناديب
فكان العدد قليل
ففيه لباس رسمي معين، لازم يلبس سترة معينة وطاقية، وإلى آخره
فكنا حريصين على انتقاء المناديب بمظهر لائق جدًّا
لأن كان عددهم قليل، وسهل أنك تسيطر عليهم
وهذا كله شغلكم... هذه سنة كم قلت لي؟
هذه تقريبًا من منتصف 2017 هذا التغير الثاني لنا، التحور الثاني
إلى أن دخلنا على 2018
في 2018 بدأت تتحسن الأمور
أنتوا بس بالرياض؟
كنا لحالنا
قصدي تخدمون الرياض؟
إيه الرياض، فعلًا كنا لحالنا ما أحد ينافسنا
بعدين 2018 دخل لاعب جديد في المنطقة
اللي هو كاريدج، كاريدج دخل الرياض
فجأة كذا شاف علامة تجارية «ذا شفز» نسخ لصق
كلهم
كلمهم، وهو استحوذت عليه شركة «دليفري هيرو»
مبلغ تقريبًا 180 مليون
قابلناه في البرنامج
إي، قابلتوه
فعندهم دعم مالي كبير وخبرات متراكمة، إلى آخره
دخلوا السوق، وشافوا أحلى أو أفضل فكرة
أن يدخلوا السوق هذا يستهدفوا المطاعم اللي احنا كنا شغالين معها
بس هم ما كانوا يخدمون في السعودية المأكولات السريعة؟
في بدايتهم لا، كانوا حاصرين على المطاعم المرتبة
فشافوا في فرصة أنهم ينافسونكم بدال ما...
فجأة احنا بدأنا نخسر علامات تجارية
فجأة علامات تجارية يدقون علينا يقول: نبي نقفل
ليش؟
موقع حصري معهم؟
إيه، اكتشفنا أن يتصلون عليهم
وقع معي حصري، وراح أعطيك 200 ألف ريال
فكانوا يعطون عروض خرافية
ما أحد يعطي 200 ألف ريال
رصيد تكون المفروض
فكان إيه رصيد، فهو يقول: تعال راح أعطيك 200 ألف ريال رصيد تسويق
إشعارات وتصوير
فبعض المطاعم قالت: وين هذا راح يعطينا 200 ألف ريال
ليش قاعد أشتغل مع «ذا شفز»
فبدأنا نخسر فحسينا بأزمة قوية تهدد وجودنا أن فيه منافس أكبر منك
فحتى أتذكر جلست مع...
هذا اللي يزعل أني أقول اسمه وللا لا، هو...
راح نحط طوط
إيه، حط طوط
فاشتغل معهم كمسشار مبيعات يربطهم مع ملاك المطاعم
بحيث يساعدهم على عملية تسريع إضافة...
يربط مين بمين؟
يربط كاريدج، يعني هو يجي لكاريدج
ويقول: تعالوا أنا أعرفكم على العلامات تجارية هذه
أنا أعرفهم بحكم علاقة سابقة
بحكم تخصصه في القطاع، وهذا شيء من حقه
فجلست معه، قال لي: يا عبدالرحمن انحش
قابلته في مقهى، قال لي: يا عبدالرحمن انحش
قال: هؤلاء عندهم ميزانية ضخمة
عندهم 15 مليون يصرفونها في التسويق
كاريدج؟
كاريدج، فأنا بالنسبة لي 15 مليون رقم مرعب
والله ما أنساها، قال: راح يأكلون الأخضر واليابس
انحش، قفّل وللا شوف لك صرفة
ففعلًا خفنا أن الآن دخل علينا واحد ينافسنا
في تلك الفترة حاولنا أن نجيب مستثمرين
قلنا: نحتاج احنا موارد مالية أعلى أن نصرف ونتوسع
للأسف كانت جميع محاولاتنا فاشلة
قابلنا أغلب الصناديق في 2018
كلهم يقولوا: يا أخي أنت سوق المحيط الأحمر
السوق مليان....
مليان، ما أقدر أستثمر فيه، ولا أعتقد أن فيه فرصة
كملنا، نمونا كان ممتاز بس ما كان أفضل
بدأ شوي المطاعم يستوعبون أن ما راح يعطيك 200 ألف ريال نقدًا
بدأوا المطاعم يشوفون ميزة «ذا شفز»
أن عميل «ذا شفز» المتوسط حقه عالي جدًّا
متوسط الطلب
إيه، وعميل ما يقلقك، ويبثرك ويشتكيك، عميل رائع
فكان دائمًا الانطباع اللي يجينا من المطاعم
أن يقول: عملاءكم يا أخي مرتبين، يعني مبسوطين عليهم
فالحمد الله، كملنا النمو في 2018
في 2018 تقريبًا سوينا 44 ألف طلب في السنة كاملة
في مطاعم رجعت بعدما...؟
إيه، أغلب المطاعم رجعت
السنة هذه سوّينا فيها 44 ألف طلب، الحمد لله
الأيام الحالية اللي نعيشها الآن نتجاوز الرقم هذا في الأيام العادية
اللي كنا نجيبه في سنة، الحين نجيبه في الأيام العادية، فاستمرينا
في 2019 بدأت بوادر أزمة الاستثمار تُفرج
تواصل معنا «قيس العيسى» من «فيجين»
تواصل معنا عبر لينكد إن، كذا هم من نفسهم
أيش عندكم، وأيش تسوون؟ ورحنا زرناهم في الشرقية
قالوا: احنا ودنا نستثمر في القطاع، ونعتقد أنكم مناسبين
واستثمروا معنا
قفلنا الجولة على بداية 2020
هي اللي جاءت بعدها رعاية نادي الشباب؟
لا لسه، في 2020
2020 اللي هي سنة كورونا
اللي هي السنة المحورية لأغلب تطبيقات التوصيل
في ناس يقول لك: أن كثير من التطبيقات استفادت
وهذا الكلام صحيح، بس أيضًا في تطبيقات فشلت في كورونا
لأنها كانت أزمة في كورونا
أزمة أنك تجيب مناديب، وأنك توظف
أنا ودي أن نتجاوزها لأن كورونا يمكن أشبعناها نقاش
خلال حلقات كثير ماضية
فصارت فيه أزمة أكيد حتى كتشريعات وكتفاصيل هذه كلها
إيه، عانينا بصراحة
بس بعدما تجاوزتوها؟
حتى توسعنا للمدن، ترى كنا وقتها أغلبها في الرياض
توسعنا في جدة نهاية 2019 وبداية 2020
بس أن كان التوسع الحقيقي لنا في كورونا
تخيل أنا أفتح مدن، ما أقدر أوظف، في حظر تجول
وهذا الشيء، معلومة طريفة أن الآن أغلب مدراء «ذا شفز»
خصوصًا في القسم التشغيلي، كانوا مناديب
كانوا مناديب يشتغلون معنا
لأن خلال السنة هذه كان التوظيف صعب
فكان أسرع طريقة أنك توظف
تشوف من المندوب اللي فاهم شغلك، وفاهم السوق
وعنده تعامل كويس مع المطاعم، وإنسان لبق
فكنا نفلترهم المناديب اللي عندنا
ونسحبهم، ونسوي له مقابلة شخصية
تعال أنت امسك خدمة العملاء
أنت امسك خدمة دعم الـ...
وضبط الموضوع
كله الآن، ما شاء الله، جميع القيادات في «ذا شفز» كانوا مناديب
وهذا شيء نفخر فيه
احنا كلنا هنا، أنت لازم تعيش التجربة، وصلنا طلبات
أتذكر «عبدالرحمن» أنا وإياه دائمًا فجأة
أدخل مطعم وأقابله، فأنت أيش جابك؟ والله أوصل طلب
تبي تجرب، تشوف التجربة
لا والله، مو تجربة «مُجبر أخاك لا بطل»
وقتها كان يجي...، نظام حتى الطلبات
أنك تحاول تتخطون مع المناديب
إيه، أدور بالواتساب، كنت مجمع لي واتساب فيه مناديب
أرسل لهم، أقول: في طلب من اللي يقبله؟
ما فيه أتمتة، شغل يدوي
ما جاء أحد، أطلع أنا أوصل الطلب أو «عبدالرحمن» يطلع
وكانت تجربة، مثلما قلت: تتعلم
وتختلط بالناس، وتحصل فلوس
كنا نحصّل من دخل التوصيل، وأيضًا بخشيش
وقتها كنا نعتمد على التوصيل نقدًا
كان مثلًا الحساب خلنا نقول: ثمانين ريال، يعطيك 100 ريال
يشوفك سعودي مرتب كذا، يقول: اخذ العشرين ريال الباقي لك بخشيش
فكانت تجربة استفدنا، وتعلمنا منها
عاد إلى 2020، تسريعًا للأمام
كنت تسأل عن نادي الشباب
هذه فعلًا كانت أول رعاية لنا في...
هذه بعد الجولة الاستثمارية؟
بعد الجولة الاستثمارية، ليش؟
لأن في الفترة هذه مع كورونا وما قبل كورونا
كنا مركزين على المطاعم الراقية هذه
وكان شريحة العملاء اللي عندنا أغلبهم فئة عمرية عالية شوي
اللي عندهم القدرة الشرائية العالية
احنا قلنا: نبغى نتوسع، ليش؟
لأن في كورونا المطاعم اللي كانت تشتغل معنا شبه حصري
فتحت الباب، قالت: أنا الآن عندي ضعف في الطلبات
خصوًصا أوقات الحجر أبي أفتحه للكل
سمعتها، كثير من مطاعم الراقية تنازلوا
انسى عن التموضع
أبي فلوس، أبي أسدد رواتب
توصل سباكين ما عندي مشكلة، تعال اشتغل
فهذا الشيء نوعًا ما شفناه أنه خطر علينا
أن المنافسين دخلوا على سوقنا
فقلنا: أيش أفضل حل؟ ندخل على سوقهم
فبدأنا في 2020 أن ندخل المأكولات السريعة
فكنا نقول وقتها أن الشريحة العمرية اللي اكتسبناها وكوّناها شريحة مميزة
بس أنهم مو دائمًا يطلبون المأكولات السريعة
اللي يطلب المأكولات السريعة فئة الشباب أكثر شيء
فقلنا: خلنا ندخل القطاع الرياضي
لأن القطاع الرياضي هو أفضل قطاع تقدر أنت تتواصل معه مع فئة الشباب
فاخترنا عاد...
نادي الشباب، وافقت، وكانت تجربة مميزة
اشتغلنا معهم سنة تعاقدية
وحقق الشباب المركز الثاني
كان راح يصير الأول بس هُزِم قدام الهلال
الحمد لله
لا، كان في طرد «بانيقا» طرد ظالم
كلنا نشجع الشباب
شبابيين أنتم تشجعون؟
لا، وقتها
وقتها عشان الشغل
إيه، لا أنا ما أشجع، أشجع الهلال
بس كنت أشجع الشباب ضد الهلال
هذا قاعد يشيل العلامة التجارية تبعي
واستفدنا، ودخلنا على محيط جديد، وفئة جديدة اللي هم الشباب
أنا ما راح أعلق على الشباب، التجربة
ما يُمَزح معهم أبد، هذا الشيء اكتشفته مؤخرًا في تويتر
جمهوره متحمس مرة مع ناديه
جمهور الشباب تفاعله قوي في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وأعتقد أنه استلهم تفاعله وطاقته من رئيسهم «خالد البلطان»
فممكن نشطح شوي
اللي سواه، خصوصًا في السنة تلك شيء ثورة في عالم الاستثمار
أن أول الأندية تجيب لها راعي أو راعيين وبس من العلامات تجارية الكبيرة
شركات طيران و«إس تي سي»
لا، هو سوّى نقلة نوعية
أن بدل ما أنا أجيب علامتين تجارية
أفتح الباب للعلامات التجارية المحلية اللي يصير فيها تفاعل أكثر
هذه كانت جدًّا مميزة، واستضفنا «عامر الظفيري»
«عامر» هو كان مدير
استضفناه، وتكلم، وكانت فعلًا تجربة جدًّا مميزة
حتى في شركات كثيرة كانت أول تجربة لها أصلًا أنها ترعى نادي
وأندية كثيرة قلدت النموذج هذا
2020 كانت مليئة بالأحداث، وشهدت نمو بالنسبة لنا
كانت صعبة، ونمو ممتاز
في نهاية 2020 أيضًا سوينا شيء جديد ما كنا بصراحة مخططين له
اللي هو خدمة الحجوزات
في نهاية السنة 2020 أطلقوا فعالية «أواسيس» إذا تذكرها
حقت موسم الرياض؟
إيه «أواسيس» فعالية مصاحبة لموسم الرياض
اللي هي للي ما يعرف، أخذوا مكان في الثمامة
رتبوه، وجابوا مطاعم فخمة
واحتاجوا منصة تدير الحجوزات، وتذاكر الدخول
فكلموا أكثر من منصة، وكلمونا ما أدري ليش
كان واحد يعتقد أن عندنا حجوزات، بس ما عندنا
فدق علينا قال: عندكم حجوزات؟
لأن هؤلاء يبحثون عن مزودين خدمة
قلنا: إيه، عندنا حجوزات
قال: تعال سوي عرض تقديمي
أنتم كان عندكم نظام حجوزات؟
ما كان عندنا، ولا كنا مخططين تمامًا
حلو
قال: تعال سوي بكرة عرض تقديمي
سوي تجربة، وورينا
اعرض لنا النظام حقك اللي ما هو موجود أساسًا
قلت له: ما ينفع أنا أجي، قال: لا
قلت: اسمع أنا عندي الفريق التقني برة السعودية
على بال ما أجيبهم، وتأشيرات
أحتاج، أعطيني أسبوع، فوافق، أعطاني أسبوع
خلال الأسبوع هذا على طول أنا أول ما قفلت منه
رحت كلمت الفريق التقني
كان وقتها معنا «رمزي القريني» توّه داخل
فقلت له: «رمزي» لازم هذا الشيء يطلع
قال: مستحيل يا عبدالرحمن
قلت: أبغى أول شيء صور حط لي شاشات تضغط ويفتح
بس فعليًّا ما تسوي شيء
نموذج أوّلي
نموذج أوّلي، مو مربوطة بالشبكة ولا...
فرحنا جلسنا معهم وريناهم، وانبسطوا
أخذنا منهم تقييم، أعطيناهم انطباع أن احنا جديدين بس مركزين
نعطيكم كامل انتباهنا
نعطيكم كامل انتباهنا، زائد نسوي لكم اللي تبون
احنا مو عندنا حل ماخذينه
لا، احنا نطور الحل اللي يتناسب مع احتياجاتكم
فكان عندهم احتياجات غريبة
مو غريبة يعني مميزة
بس مختلفة عن السوق السعودي عن السوق الخارجي
طريقة الحجوزات والتنظيم
لأن احنا مو فقط أدرنا أنك تحجز طاولة، لا
حتى وأنت داخل، يستقبلك موظف الأمن
يتأكد أن حجزك صحيح، طيب إذا ما في إنترنت
طالعين في البر، كيف يشيك؟
جاء واحد والحجز خمسة، كيف يدخلون؟
فهم كانوا يبغون التجربة كاملة بأنظمتها
تشييك الدخول وحجز الطاولات
كل شيء
والله أنت قادح
سوينا تخيل مشروع فعليًّا يأخد المفروض أشهر بل سنوات
سويناه في عشرين يوم بعدما اتفقنا معهم على الشاشات
وجلسنا نماطل
كيف أقنعت فريقك أنه...؟
والله بحب الخشوم، جيتهم أول شيء بالوقت الإضافي، بعطيكم زيادة
خارج الدوام بس اشتغل
إيه، خارج الدوام بس اشتغل
اقتنعوا شوي بعدين قالوا: يا أخي احنا عندنا حياتنا، وما نبي فلوسك
فتجيهم في الطيب، تكفون هذا مستقبلنا
فما قصر الفريق التقني
سوينا المنتج، وفادنا أصلًا، كان راح ينطلق الموسم، وتأخر شوي
أعطانا وقت، بدأنا والتجربة كانت ناجحة في 2021 بدايتها
ثم دخلنا عاد على موسم الرياض
لأن «أواسيس» كان مختلف عن موسم الرياض
دخلنا عاد موسم الرياض نهاية السنة
اللي تتطور فيها نظامنا، وصار معقد أكثر، وخدمات كثيرة
ما مريتوا بمشاكل مع موسم الرياض؟
مشاكل؟
كنت توّك، باسم الله، مسوّي النظام
ما قد اشتغلت قبل كذا، ما عندك أي خبرة في الموضوع
فما مريت بمشاكل بالبدايات معهم؟
تصير بعض المشاكل، لكن إذا أنت شخص اللي جالس تطور نظام
والفريق عندك، والفريق ما أثني على الفريق بس كفاءتهم عالية جدًّا
فأي مشكلة نقدر نحلها بسرعة
فهذا الشيء خلاهم يرتاحون لنا
أن عندهم واحد جالس معهم
فكنا نروح لهم نتكي هناك في الطعوس
على لابتوباتنا، أي شيء تبونه نعدل بسرعة
فأعطاهم الأريحية أن لا هذا شريك تقني يقدرون يثقون فيه
فقدرنا ندخل على موسم الرياض اللي كان أكبر اللي هو في نهاية السنة
دخلنا كراعي، وكانت تجربة مميزة
كان بالنسبة لنا كتطبيق يدخل موسم الرياض
وموسم كبير وفعالية تطبيق جديد يدخل
أعطانا دفعة كبيرة جدًّا
وكملتوا كم سنة مع الموسم؟
كملنا كراعي، مع العلم أنها ما هي سهلة أنك تدخل كراعي
أنت دخلت راعي دافع فلوس وللا؟
دافع ومش دافع، احنا نقدم خدمات يسمونها مساهمات عينية
زائد أن احنا ندفع، ونحن...
ما هي بواضحة
هل أنت سعّرت قيمة خدماتك، واعتبرتها جزء من قيمة الرعاية؟
راح أعلمك السالفة، أنا كنت مصمم أني أدخل موسم الرياض
وأعرف المنافسة فيه صعبة جدًّا
وأعرف أنهم راح يطلبون مبلغ عالي
وممكن أنا ما أقدر على المبلغ هذا، أيش سويت؟
قلت: ما لي إلا أكلم معالي المستشار، تركي آل الشيخ
دورنا إلى أن جبت رقمه
أرسلت له رسالة طويلة، احنا شباب سعودي، أعطيته الكليشة
واحنا سوينا مع موسم الرياض، واحنا نبغى دعمكم
قلت: راح أرسل، إذا رد، أيش أسوأ شيء ممكن يصير؟
ما يرد، وممكن يعطيني بلوك كمان
فأرسلت فجأة، على طول الدقيقة اللي بعدها رد
قال لي: الله يحييك تواصل مع فلان
منو فلان؟ ما أعرف منو فلان
وعيب أني أرجع أسأله منو فلان
فعرفنا من هو فلان
فصرت أمشي أقول: أنا موجهني معالي المستشار تركي آل الشيخ
قدرنا نشتغل معهم أن في مبلغ ندفعه، ومبلغ قيمة التكلفة
لأن احنا ما ندخل فقط في النظام
احنا نوظف خلال فترة الموسم ستة شهور
نجيب ناس دوام جزئي يشتغلوا معنا
يشرفون على موظفي الأمن والاستقبال، أنظمة معينة
هم النظام والموظفين يبغونهم منك؟
كلها احنا كنا نقدمها للمشرفين على النظام وإدارة الحجوزات
زائد أن كانت تكلفتها عالية
مثلًا الرسالة النصية، لو سجل واحد من برة السعودية
خلنا نقول من الإمارات، عشان نرسل له تأكيد الحجز وبيانات الحجز
تكلفنا الرسالة ثلاثة وأربعين ريال
ثلاثة وأربعين ريال؟
مزود الخدمة، لأن مو نرسل رسالة واحدة
أول شيء عفوًا نرسل له رسالة، هذا حجزك، ادفع
تم استقبال حجزك، أكّدناه بعدين تذكير
نرسل له ثلاث رسائل
مجموع الرسائل ثلاثة وأربعين
للعميل الواحد
إيه، للعميل الواحد
العميل الواحد ثلاثة وأربعين ريال تكلف
وأنا دخلي بعض الأحيان ما يغطي
كانوا يدفعون لكم قبل شيء، وللا؟
لا، كنا احنا نأخد نسبة بسيطة نغطي فيها الرسوم البنكية
لأن فيها دفع إلكتروني
فالعميل لما يدفع الحين فيزا وماستر
مزود الخدمة يدفع مبلغ للبنك أو للشركة الوسيطة
فكنا نأخذ نسبة عشان نغطيه
فأنت حسبت تكلفة النظام، ما أدري إذا حسبت تكلفة تطويره أيضًا
رواتب الموظفين اللي راح يساهمون في عمل النظام
وقلت: هذه قيمتها، زائد الباقي راح أعطيكم الفرق نقد
زائد أننا احنا شباب سعوديين
لا بس أن برضو فيه، اللي هو مبلغ الرعاية 10 مليون
والتكاليف حقتك 5 مليون، دفعت 5 مليون نقد
صحيح
كذا سويتها؟
فعلًا هذا اللي سويناه، والحمد لله، الاستراتيجية جيّدة، ونجحت معنا
كملنا أثبتنا وجودنا وكملنا، الحمد لله، الموسم الأول والثاني
والثالث الأخير اللي احنا نعيشه
حلو، والخدمات اللي تقدمونها اليوم أيش هي؟
أنا دخلت التطبيق أنا أطلب من فترة لفترة المطاعم اللي أو المقاهي
مو مقاهي، محلات حلويات إي
أنتم متخصصين اليوم أحس أكثر شيء في محلات الحلويات
احنا إيه، عندنا متاجر كثير حلويات متميّزين في هذا الشيء
واحنا المرجع، تقريبًا 46% من مبيعاتنا في الحلويات والكيك
حسنًا، أيش الخدمات؟
عندك حجوزات بكافة أنواع الفعاليات، حسب ما فهمت
أذكر أنا قد حجزت من زمان، في رمضان كان
حجزت الخيمة رمضانية حجزتها من «ذا شفز»
أيش عندكم؟ بعد عندكم التوصيل المجدول والعادي
أيش في أشياء ثانية تسوونها؟
خلنا نتكلم، احنا لما بنينا الشركة
في نوعين من الشركات
في شركات اللي يسمونها (Surface Centric)
يعني شركة قائمة على خدمة معينة
احنا قلنا: لا، احنا نبغى الشركة قائمة على عميل معين
حددنا العميل، العميل الراقي اللي يقدر يدفع سعر معين
بعدين قلنا: أيش الخدمات اللي يحتاجها العميل؟
فسوينا توصيل، توصيل لحظي تستلم الآن أو مجدول
سوينا استلام، تقدر تستلم بنفسك، تروح المطعم، وتستلم بنفسك
ما يحتاج مندوب
سوينا خدمة الحجوزات
سوينا خدمة طبخ، أنت مثلًا اليوم طالعين شاليه مع عائلتكم
حابين تطلبون شاحنة طعام
أحد يطبخ لكم
إيه، أنتم في الدوام مثلًا غداء تبون استراحة قهوة، سوّينا خدمة التموين
سوّينا خدمة الإهداء
أنت الحين مثلًا، مو شرط تبي تهدي واحد لازم تهديه وردة
تذكر المناسبات الجميلة اللي مرت عليك
أغلب هداياك ورد، صح؟
إيه
إذا أنت تهدي
كان في البداية كذا بس بعدين مليت
أتوقع حتى اللي حولي ملوا ما صاروا يهدون ورد
لأن صار تعرف اللي الظاهر أن كل الناس يجيهم من مكان واحد
ونفس التطبيق، وبالأخير بطلنا كلنا فجأة
لأن في الإهداء تبغى تنقل شعور أني أنا تعنيت في التجربة لك
فالورد بعد ثالث مرة تحس أنه خلاص
فاحنا عندنا في «ذا شفز» تقدر تهدي برقر
أنت جوك برقر، أنت يسعد جوك برقر، أنا أهديك برقر
أنت أهديك قهوة، أقدر أهديك قهوة
شاورما
شاورما، راح تجيك رسالة في الواتساب أن مثلًا مشهور
عاد تقدر تحط بدون اسمك
والله شخص عزيز عليك يبغى يهديك شاورما
قبول وللا رفض؟ وتحدد الوقت والمكان
فهذه الخدمة مرة مميزة
بعدين فتحنا الورود، فأنت قبل شوية تتكلم أتوقع تقصد فلاورد
فلاورد منافس قوي في السوق
احنا قلنا: أيضًا نبي، لاحظ ننافس أكثر
في كل خدمة ننافس واحد
فقلنا: في الورود أيضًا نبي ننافس فلاورد
وشلون؟
فلاورد نموذجهم أنه هو يشتري المنتج بنفسه
يجهزه ويصلحه ويوصله
احنا قلنا: نبغى نشتغل بنظام المُجمّع
اللي يجمع الطلب، ويعتمد على المحلات اللي تشتغل
كم محل عندك في السعودية؟ عدد كثير جدًّا
أيش الفرق بين النموذجين؟
النموذج الأول، نموذج اللي هو نموذج فلاورد
عندة قدرة أكثر أنه يتحكم في سعره والجودة
ممكن يحقق مبيعات أعلى بس ممكن يتأثر في الربحية
لأن فيها تكلفة
بس هذا اللي نجّح فلاورد، وما خلى ناس
أذكر هم رسالة، الظاهر
في شركات قبل حاولت تسوي النموذج هذا
مع محلات الورد ولا ضبط موضوعها
مشاكل في الجودة والتوصيل وتوفر المنتجات
إيه، أنت لازم تحلها
كل المشاكل هي تعتبر تحديات، فلازم تحلها
فاحنا لا، رحنا مع النموذج الثاني
اللي هو أنا بدل ما يكون عندي عدد محدود من خيارات الإهداء
200 إهداء، 200 مثلًا توزيعة أو 200 تشكيلة من الورد
أنا أقدر أجيب لك 30 ألف خيار في الإهداء
فهذا الشيء اللي سويناه
فاحنا الحين عندنا متاجر الورود
عندنا أكثر من 30 ألف سلة أو بوكيه تقدر أنت تهديه
فهذا يعطيك تنوع أكثر، ويعطيك تنوع سعري أكثر
خلاص ما أنت محكور على سعر معين
الناس تعتبره غالي خلاص
لا، احنا عندنا في متاجر تبيع لك سعر رخيص وفي متوسط وغالي
فهذا النموذج اللي يسمونه المُجمّع
أنك تعتمد على...، زي تطبيقات التوصيل
يساعدك أنك تنمو، ويساعدك أنك تكبر
زائد أنك أنت نجاحك من نجاح الآخرين
في عندكم برضو هذه اليوم اكتشفتها بالغلط
كنت أبي أطلب من محل مخبز، بعدين دخلت محل ثاني
وجيت أبي أطلب، وطلع أقدر أطلب من اثنين مع بعض بنفس الطلب
عندنا متاجر تقدر أنت تطلب
مثلًا نسميها «ذا شفز بوتيك»
تقدر تطلب أكثر من متجر في عملية توصيل واحدة
هل المتاجر هذه لازم يكونوا متعاقدين معكم بطريقة معينة؟
لها علاقة في الموضوع هذا؟
إيه، احنا نسويها بطريقة تقنية معينة
هل هو مطبخ سحابي؟
غالبًا مطابخ سحابية
فمو أي مطعم؟
إيه، مو أي مطعم
احنا عندنا مصطلح اللي يسمونه المتاجر السحابية
عكس المطابخ
احنا من أوائل الناس اللي دخلوا في المجال هذا من 2020
عندنا، الحمد لله، أكثر من ستة عشر متجر سحابي
توزعه في أنحاء الـ...
أيش فرق المتجر السحابي عن المطبخ السحابي؟
مثلًا خلنا نقول: أنت علامة تجارية في الشرقية
عندك حلى معين تبغى تنقل الرياض
احنا نجي نشحن لك، نستلم من عندك في الدمام مثلًا
بسيارات مبردة، ونشحنها عندنا في الرياض
نوزعها في نقاط البيع اللي في الرياض
نشحنها لجدة، عندنا نقاط في جدة
نشحنها إلى القصيم، أو نشحنها إلى الجنوب، خميس وجازان
فتقدر تنتشر في أسبوع واحد
احنا نمسك الخدمات اللوجستية بالكامل، فنعطيك نقاط توزيع أكثر
فتصير موجود أكثر، فالعميل إذا فتح تطبيقك
أو فتحت تطبيقنا، يقدر يشوف علامتك التجارية، قريب
فعليًّا هي تخزين وتوزيع؟
تخزين، نسميها «خدمة الإنجاز»
بس ما في مطابخ سحابية بعد؟
لا، ما دخلنا في المجال هذا حتى الآن
احنا مركزين لأن قوتنا فعليًّا
غالبية العلامات التجارية اللي احنا نبيعها في الحلويات
احنا رقم واحد بالنسبة لهم
فاحنا أي أثر نسويه راح يصير فيه عائد قوي لهم
فركزنا في هذه الفكرة
سمعت أنكم برضو ما تقفلون حدود التوصيل
إي
أنا أقدر أطلب من لو أني في النسيم
أطلب من «نرجس»
صحيح
هذه شلون...
لأن احنا شوف نموذجنا...
ترتفع عليك بشكل كبير تكلفة التوصيل
إيه، شوف، احنا ما نقفلها
العميل يقدر، يبغى خدمة، وقابل بسعر التوصيل
وعارف المسافة بعيدة، ويبغى المنتج هذا، يطلب
احنا كنا نوصل للخرج من الدمام، كنا فاتحين
نوصل مثلًا نهاية العمّارية
والمندوب الضعيف؟
يستلم سعر التوصيل، على فكرة احنا ما نأخذ شيء من سعر التوصيل
الفلوس اللي تجينا نعطيها المندوب كاملة
بل بالعكس احنا من أكثر التطبيقات اللي تعطي زيادات
فوق الـ...
فوق البيعة، ونضاعف، ونعطي ونسحب جوائز، سيارات وجوالات
الفترة الأخيرة سحبنا على عدد معين من السيارات أعطيناها مناديب
فاحنا حريصين أن العلاقة تكون يسمونها ربح ربح ربح
أذكر مرة قد سولفنا عن سالفة المندوب إذا صارت له مشكلة
أو تأخر أكثر من اللازم في مطعم، تعوضونه
نعوض المندوب احنا
أيش فكرتها هذه؟ معليش اشرحها
المندوب بشر، أنا كنت مندوب
أنا كنت أطلع أوصل، تجربة تراها ليست سهلة
وصعبة جدًّا، توقف آخر الشارع وتنتظر بالطابور
التعامل في المطعم ممكن ما يكون لائق
العامل الأجنبي يمكن يعاملك بنظرة مختلفة
تأخذ الطلب، وتروح للعميل، قابلني في الدور السادس
يطق عليه ما يفتح، فهذه تجربة صعبة
فوقته، أنت تكافئه لوقته
فاحنا عندنا نظام أن المندوب إذا تأخر عليه المطعم وقت معين
احنا نعوض المندوب
مع أنه مشكلة، المندوب يقضي وقت إلى ساعة في مطعم معين
ما يقول: ليتني...
لا، بس احنا ما نحطه كذا عشان ما يقعد يتكي في المطعم
احنا ضابطينها بطريقة أن الأفضل لك أنك تطلع توصّل
لكن بعد وقت معين، أنت راح تُعطَى حقك
وارتفاع سعر متوسط الطلب الواحد
هو اللي خلاكم تحطون «تمارا» بعد؟
لا، احنا طبعًا أطلقنا «تمارا»
احنا عندنا خدمات التموين، وخدمات الحجوزات
متوسط السعر عالي جدًّا
بعضهم يطلب «تمارا»
هل معناته أن «تمارا» مقفلينها على أنواع معينة من الطلبات؟
لا، احنا فاتحينها الآن، بس في ناس يبغى «تمارا»
«عبدالمجيد» والشباب قد جلست معهم من زمان قبل سنتين
كنت أقول له: لا، ما نبغى «تمارا»
أنا ليش أقعد أشجع الناس أن يطلب شيء مو قادر يدفع حقه؟
«عبدالمجيد» اللي هو الرئيس التنفيذي لـ«تمارا»
إيه، فاكتشفت بعد فترة أن لا
أن في ناس يستخدم «تمارا» كأسلوب للتقسيم
خلني أقول لك: يحافظ على مصروفه
يعرف كيف توزيع مصروفه، أنا راح أدفع الآن
بعدين أدفعها على نهاية الشهر
وعندهم خدمات إضافية
بس تدري أيش الإشكالية، على الأقل من وجهة نظري؟
أشوف في أشياء كثيرة عندكم، ما هي موجودة عند ناس ثانيين
زي «تمارا» والحجوزات يمكن في تطبيقات ثانية دخلوا فيها
بس ما أدري أيش اللي يخليني أروح لـ«ذا شفز»
أشوف مثلًا لو أبي أضرب أمثلة
جاهز ممكن مثلًا أبغى أروح له
إذا أنا مثلًا مستعجل مرة على الطلب
وأثق فيهم إلى حد ما
أن أعرف أن في عشرين دقيقة، ولا هو طاق الباب البيت وجاي
مرسول، ممكن أقول أنا أبغى أروح له
إذا أنا أبغى أضمن أن تفاصيل الطلب تجيني
كتخصيص، إذا في تجربة تخصيص أكثر أضمن أن تكون
أو أني أبغى أطلب شيء خارج مو موجود
هنقرستيشن ما أدري ليش أروح له؟
نفس الأمر، أسرع شيء
لا، تجربتي ما هي أسرع شيء
بس أن خلنا نقول أبي توصيل مجاني أو خيارات أكثر أو أيًّا كان
أيش اللي يجيبني لـ«ذا شفز»؟
في كل قيمة تقدر أنت تشاركها مع منافسينك، وتنافس فيها المنافسين
مثلًا أسرع شيء
أغلب التطبيقات يقول لك: أنا أوصّل في ثلاثين دقيقة، صح وللا لا؟
الثاني يقول: أنا أوصّل في تسعة وعشرين دقيقة
بعدين يجي هذا يقول: أنا أوصّل في ثمانية وعشرين
فقيمة غير قابلة للمنافسة، أنه أسرع شيء
الصدق كل التطبيقات سريعة اليوم
إيه، ما تقدر تقول أنا أسرع شيء
طيب، هذا ممكن يسبقك بدقيقة
بكرة أنت تبي تروح...، إلى متى أسرع شيء؟
فاحنا لا، ما ركزنا أن...
احنا نقدم الخدمة بالوقت اللي يختاره العميل
فإذا اخترت أنت، عندنا خدمة أسرع شيء أو اللحظي
يعطيك الوقت المتوقع، وتقدر تخليه جدولة
احنا هدفنا أن نوصل الطلب على متطلبات العميل
هو يبغاها جدولة بعد أسبوع
وهو يبغى المندوب يكلمه قبل استلام الطلب
احنا عندنا خاصية أن المندوب يكلمك قبل استلام الطلب
كثير من الناس كان يدق علي يقول: يا أخي هذا الخاصية مزعجة شيلوها
فعلًا
أنا عرفت أغلب الشباب ما يحبون الخاصية هذه
أمس كنا نحش فيها بالاستراحة
بينما في ناس كثير تسألهم، واحنا نسوي استبيان
أن يحبون الخاصية هذه خصوصًا فئة الإناث
خليتوها اختياري شفت الـ...
خليناها اختياري، في خصوصًا البنات أن لازم يدق عليها
ويتأكد أن الكيكة مكتوب، وورني، وصور
فهذه احنا مختلفين شوي عن الآخرين
تجربتنا ليست أن نركز أن دائمًا احنا خدمتنا وقيمتنا
اللي نوعد فيها العميل أننا أسرع شيء، لا
احنا قيمتنا أن احنا دائمًا في الوقت اللي يختاره العميل
بس أيش تعتقد الشيء الواحد اللي يميزكم عن الباقيين؟
يعني لو تأخذ ميزة واحدة تميزكم عن كل الباقيين في السوق
أيش تتوقع تكون؟
في السوق هذا مثلما قلت لك قصة كاريدج
دخلوا علينا كاريدج، وقالوا: عنده فلوس
واحنا دخلنا برأس مال متواضع جدًّا
جلسنا ننافس شركات مليارية
وشركات دخلت برأس مال يتجاوز الـ100 مليون
وعندها دعم لا محدود
احنا شلون ننافسهم؟
احنا كان عندنا الاعتقاد من اليوم الأول
وهذا الشيء اللي جالسين نسعى له يوميًّا
ونؤمن أن ما رح نوصله لـ 100% اللي هي خدمة العملاء، العميل نفسه
احنا دائمًا...، حتى الشباب كنا في اجتماع
قالوا جملة حول التشغيل مميزة
اللي هي قالوا: احنا العميل فرد من أسرة «ذا شفز»
و«ذا شفز» فرد من أسرة العميل
احنا الشيء اللي نراهن عليه العميل
العميل ما يهمه أنت تطبيقك تبع فلان
وللا تبع الشركة الفلانية، وللا عندك مبلغ كذا
بس عمليًّا أيش يترجم هذا الشيء؟
يترجم الخدمة، أنت الآن لما أنا أدخل التطبيق
أرتاح في التجربة، أنك أنت شفت وجربت
نحاول أن نغير لأن في ناس يقلدون الواجهة
فتجربتنا الجديدة أن لا، مثلًا معتمدين على التقييمات
التطبيقات الثانية ما يحب التقييمات والتعليقات
أن تكون في الأطباق، أنا كثير من الشباب كانوا يقول لي: لا
أو المطاعم، كانوا يقولوا: شيل التعليقات
بالنسبة لي لا، شيء جوهري
أنا شخصيًّا لما أروح أسيّر على شباب، وللا أبي أخذ لي حلى مثلًا
دائمًا أطلب من علامات تجارية ما أعرفها تمامًا
بس أعتمد على تقيمات العملاء
دائمًا أتفاجئ بالمنتج جودة عالية جدًّا
فهذه أحد عناصر التجربة
أن التجربة واقعية تساعد العميل، منطقية
ما هي صور تضغط...
المطاعم ما يزعلون منها هذه والمحلات؟
احنا دائمًا في صف الكل، احنا نقول مطاعم
احنا عشان نكون منطقيين، في ناس يظلمون في التقييم
تشوفهم أنت في خرائط قوقل كيف يظلمون بالتعليقات
وتصير عندنا في ناس يكتبوا تعليقات مجحفة
فاحنا عندنا أيضًا خاصية أن ينقون العلامة التجارية
واحنا بشكل عام نتابع التعليقات هذه
إذا شفناها تعليق المشكلة، نقدر نحلها، نكلم العميل
نقول: تسمح لنا نشيل تعليقك؟ لأن المشكلة هذه حليناها
فإذا وافق، نشيل التعليق، أو إذا طلب مننا...
فهل تركيزكم على العميل، وتقديمكم خدمة مميزة هو سبب...
وهذا الشيء انطباع قد يكون خاطئ
أنكم أغلى توصيل من كل التطبيقات؟
هذا انطباع خاطئ، توصيلنا يبدأ من أربعة عشر ريال
بس الحين كلهم مباشرة يتوجهون على خمسة أو سبعة أو مجاني
اي احنا عندنا مجاني كثير، احنا أكثر منتج...
نسبة وتناسب، لا والله بالعدد احنا قسناها
أكثر تطبيق في عدد علامات تجارية توصّل مجاني
لأن العلامة التجارية أيضًا للمطعم لما يدخل معك توصيل مجاني
لازم يكون له عائد
لأن أغلب التطبيقات والكل يستقطع نسبة من سعر التوصيل المجاني
يحمّلها المطعم، صح وللا لا؟
فالعلاقة هذه لازم تصير علاقة مستدامة
أنتم أيش...
غير كذا ما راح تكمل
أيش تسوون أنتم؟
احنا لا، فعلًا احنا أقل تطبيق يستقطع على المتاجر
بشكل عام بغض النظر عن التوصيل المجاني؟
للتوصيل، فئات التوصيل المجاني
لو تدخل وتشوف التوصيل المجاني
الأربعة عشر ريال جزء منها يتحمله «ذا شفز» وجزء يتحمله المطعم
زائد أن احنا عندنا الميزة الأساسية
أن متوسط سعر الطلبات عندنا أعلى، فالمطعم يحصّل
بس الاستقطاع الأساسي للطلبات الاعتيادية
هل عندهم أعلى، وللا أقل من الباقيين؟
متوسط احنا، متوسط تقريبًا لا...
كم تقريبًا؟
احنا بصراحة نقيسها على كل قطاع
احنا مقسمين التصنيفات عفوًا الأكل
تصنيفات الحلى لحال، والكيك والبرقر والشاورما
في عندنا تصنيفات كثيرة
تصنيفات المأكولات السريعة ما أقدر أخذ منه 20%
المأكولات السريعة أصحاب الهوامش الضئيلة
ما أقدر أقول: أعطيني 20%
ممكن أقدر أقول له، لأن قدرت أنا أقنع الموظف هذا
اللي يشتغل في الشركة
بس في النهاية الضرر راح يكون عليهم على المدى البعيد
فإذا جمعناها كلها وأخذنا اللي يسمونه المتوسط المحسوب
تقريبًا حدود 13% هو المتوسط
بس النسبة هذه، الحين راح يجوننا مطاعم الموقعين معهم بنسب أعلى
أنت تختار حسب القطاع حسب الحجم
حسب التصنيف
لا أحد يدق عليه يا جماعة
أكثر الطلب يجي على أيش بالضبط، على الحلويات؟
أنت قلت لي قبل شوي أن...
فعليًّا إي، النسبة جالسة تتقلص بس الغالبية ما زال حلويات
لأن طبيعة العملاء عندنا مختلفة عن باقي التطبيقات
يمكن هذه معلومة غريبة
تقريبًا 73% من عملاءنا إناث
عندكم طلبات، على التموضع حقكم
أستغرب أن عندكم، حسب ما سمعت
طلبات كثيرة في جنوب الرياض بعد
إيه
فالصورة النمطية أن جنوب الرياض
يشوفون أسعار التطبيقات مبالغ فيها، وما يبغون يطلبون منها
لا، بالعكس، يمكن الصورة النمطية
أنا عشت، وترعرعت في السويدي، وأعرف نمط الحياة
هناك الناس تحب اللمة أكثر
كل المناطق السعودية، وفي الرياض أكثر
وفي الرياض بشكل عام
بس ممكن في السويدي لأن...
تحليل شخصي، العوائل عدد أفرادها أكثر، ويجتمعون أكثر
ومناسبات أكثر أنك تطلب حلى وكيك ومعجنات
بس عكس شمال الرياض
الشمال منطقة الملقى معروفة
قصدي عكس الشمال في الجنوب
موضوع الطلب من الأكل ما يعتمدون عليه الناس
الشمال ممكن تلقى كل وجبة قاعد يطلب من تطبيقات التوصيل
صحيح
في جنوب رياضي يمكن يخلونها على قولتك لما يجتمعون سوا
لا، النمو جالس يزيد
لأن الفئة العمرية جالسة...
يعني يمكن أنا وأنت ثقافة الطلب أونلاين طلعت...
يعني بدأنا نستخدمها قبل خمس أو ست سنوات
أو سبع سنوات بالكثير أو ثمان سنوات
الجيل الجديد من يوم أنه صغير، وهو يستخدم الأونلاين
يطلب أونلاين كل شيء
فيطلب ملابس ومستلزمات وأكل وكل حاجة
فأنا أعتقد أن لا، القطاع جالس ينمو
ما تكلمنا على فكرة عدد العملاء وعدد الطلبات والأرقام هذه
إيه
تقدر تعطيني تقدير إذا ما تبي
إيه، لا عادي، احنا عدد التحميل عندنا تقريبًا حدود 5 مليون
عدد المسجلين حدود 4 مليون
الطلبات، الحمد لله، في 2017 تقريبًا سوّينا 1300 طلب
بإجمالي 400 ألف
السنة هذه، الحمد لله، عدينا مبيعات المليار ريال سعودي
من الآن يعني قبل نهاية السنة؟
إيه، أرقامنا، الحمد لله، في نمو
مع العلم أنه مرينا بتحديات صعبة جدًّا خلال السنتين اللي راحت
هل تقدر تتكلم عن متوسط عدد الطلبات اليوم؟
لأن ماني متخيل للحين مكانكم وين في الترتيب؟
لا تقيس بعدد الأرقام
بعدد الطلبات قصدك؟
عفوًا، بعدد الطلبات
لأن احنا متوسط السعر عندنا ضعفين من أقرب واحد لنا
فالطلب اللي أسويه هو يسوي عنده اثنين واللي بعده ثلاثة
ما تحس يمكن هذا برضو موضوع انتقدونا عليه بعض الناس في حلقة «جاهز»
ما تحس أن كل تطبيق، حسب كلامي مع مختلف التطبيقات
سواءً في القطاع هذا أو قطاع ثاني
يشوف الموضوع من زاوية ممكن تخليه هو الأول
لا، ما احنا بالأول احنا، الأول واضح السوق، البيانات
هنقرستيشن، شركة مملوكة من «دليفري هيرو»
«دليفري هيرو» شركة مطروحة في السوق الألماني، وفيه دراسات كثيرة
«جاهز» مبياعتهم أيضًا معروفة
هؤلاء تقريبًا باعوا السنة اللي راحت 7 مليار، وهؤلاء 5 مليار
حجم السوق تقريبًا 14 إلى 15 مليار
هنقرستيشن تستحوذ على الغالبية حدود الـ...
وهذا أعتقد السبب أن يمكن ما جادلت فيها في حلقة «جاهز»
أن هذا الشيء اللي يشوفونه عامة الناس
سواءً الأرقام المُصرّح فيها
هذه أرقام لأسواق المال معروفة
بالضبط، سواءً اللي يشوف نشرة الإصدار
أو أنك تقول: والله مثلًا دامنا الحين على نهاية السنة
أرقامنا اللي تسمع فيها من الناس اللي يشتغلون في القطاع
بس أن اللي نعرفه عادةً أن هنقرستيشن، ثم «جاهز»
بس بعدين تصير منطقة ضبابية، ما يدرون الناس من الـ...
الافتراض أنه مرسول
إيه، مرسول، أنت هنا تجي، تعال يا مرسول
أنا أبي أقيم مرسول بنموذج توصيل المطاعم
أحسب إيراداته ومبيعاته في نموذج توصيل المطاعم فقط
وللا أبي أحسب خدمات التوصيل العادية؟
لو نأخذها على عدد الطلبات، لأنك لو تبي تشوفها بطريقة ثانية
راح تبدأ...في تفاصيل كثيرة راح تصير في الموضوع
في نسبة الاستقطاع أو تحسبها كإيرادات
أبي أعلمك، أنا كيف أقيسها؟
ما أقدر أطّلع على بيانات مرسول، ولا حتى «تو يو»
بس توصلك أرقام
احنا نقيسها من بيانات المتاجر نفسه
نأخذ عينة استطلاعية، مين أول ثلاثة يبيعون لك؟
احنا دائمًا في الثلاثة الأولى غالبية المرات
احنا دائمًا نعتقد أن حصتنا من 8% إلى 9% في السوق، جالسة تنمو
في 2019 حصتنا كانت %0.9 يعني ما وصلنا إلى واحد
فجالسين ننمو، الحمد لله
حصة «جاهز» 35%
على أي أساس تقول حصتهم 35%؟
35%
أيش المصدر، من دراساتكم أنتم؟
من مبيعاتهم السنة اللي راحت 5 مليار
حجم السوق تقريبًا 14 مليار
فأنت قاعد، أنا أحسب على الاستفتاء اللي تقول تسويه على المطاعم
احنا نعرف العلامات التجارية هذه «جاهز» يبيع لها في المناطق الفلانية
نعرف أن المناطق اللي حتى في الرياض في أحياء ثانية
ترى هنقرستيشن بعيد
نعرف علامات تجارية ثانية احنا بعيدين عنهم
فهي ما هي معلومة وحدة، لا، تختلف
بس بشكل عام كأرقام مبيعات
لا، هي المعلنة، اللي هو هنقرستيشن بعديه من؟
متى 2015؟
2013 الظاهر
2013 إي، فكان له الأسبقية
زائد عاد احنا و«تو يو» ومرسول
حلو، دام جبنا طاريهم خلينا نفتح سالفتهم الحين
«دليفري هيرو» و«جاهز» كلهم حاولوا يستحوذون عليكم
وانتهت صفقة الاستحواذ، ما تمت لأسباب مختلفة
«دليفري هيرو» متى أول مرة كلموكم؟
اللي هم يملكون هنقرستيشن
وقتها ما كانوا يملكون كامل 100%
هذا مؤخرًا
تواصلوا معنا في بداية 2021 بعد الكورونا
صار في تواصل بيننا وبينهم
أرسلوا لنا العرض المبدئي
كذا عرض على طول، ما فيه سواليف، وما في شيء؟
إلا، وقع عندي، وقع...
أنا أبي أعرف، هل تقدر تتكلم قانونيًّا الحين وللا؟
إيه، ما راح أتكلم في التفاصيل اللي... بس بشكل عام
أيش اللي أغراهم في «ذا شفز»؟
أنه عنده متوسط سعر الطلب عالي، ونمو عالي وربحية
قطاع صعب، احنا نعتقد أن قطاع الحلويات هذا
قطاع مهم وكبير، واحنا متمكنين فيه
شافوا فرصة لهم أنهم يزيدون من حصتهم السوقية
وفرصة لهم أنهم يأخذون لاعب جديد
حتى كان الكلام أن احنا نبي نأخذ نموذجكم
ونبي نطبقه على أكثر من دولة
فاحنا سوينا حجوزات وقتها
وسوينا خدمة المخازن السحابية، وسوينا الورود، وإلى آخره
فقالوا: احنا نبي نأخذكم كتجربة ناجحة نجرب في منطقة الخليج
فبدأنا معهم في أول سنة 2021
أرسلوا لنا العرض المبدئي في شهر مارس تقريبًا
اللي هو العرض الغير مُلزِم
شفناه، وحسينا أنه مناسب
قلنا: خلاص يلا الحين نبدأ
العادة في الصفقات اللي زي كذا
لما أنت تبدأ معهم يبدأ مرحلة الفحص اللي يسمونه فحص نافي للجهالة
ليش فيه في البداية عرض غير مُلزِم؟
هو أول شي يعطيك عرض غير مُلزِم
عشان تعرف تسولف معه، وللا لا؟
يتفق على النقاط العريضة أن تقييمك كذا، أنا راح أدفع كذا
إذا في نقاط جوهرية يتم ذكرها
ثم يقول لك: أبي أدخل أنا، وإياك الآن في مرحلة فحص نافي للجهالة
أنا كان ودي أشرح النقطة هذه
على أساس تعرف أنت قبلما تبدأون تكشفون أوراقكم لبعض
تكونون متفقين، على الأقل، على النقاط الأساسية
كتقييم وسعر والأمور هذه
وبعدين تبدأون إذا حسيتوا في اتفاق مبدئي غير مُلزِم
فتبدأون تكشفون أوراق، وتعطونهم التفاصيل
بالضبط، فنبدأ مرحلة الفحص اللي نعطيهم كل شيء
فهم عاد يعينون من طرفهم مستشارين قانونيين
ومستشارين ماليين، وهم فريق ضخم
«دلفري هيرو» متمرسة على الاستحواذات
عنده أربعين شركة أو أكثر هم الآن
إيه، فريق كبير، فبدأنا اشتغلنا معه، وسووا (due diligence)
يجيبون شركات «الأربع الكبار»
الشركات الكبيرة اللي تسوي عليك (due diligence)
يسوون عليك فحص على المستوى القانوني، وعلى مستوى الضرائب
وعلى مستوى المالية، وعلى التقنية
وجابوا أيضًا شركة ألمانية سوت لنا فحص سيبراني، وفحص تقني
موضوع كامل، فعليهم تكلفة بعد
وأيضًا علينا احنا تكلفة أن احنا نلتزم معهم
وعلينا تكلفة الجهد والوقت والتركيز اللي أنت تعطيه لهم
وتكلفة الفرص البديلة أنك تركز معهم ما تركز في شيء ثاني
لأن أنا لما أبدأ أوقع معك
بعد فترة الفحص النافي للجهالة
تبدأ توقع يسمونه «الإس بي أيه» اتفاقية الشراء
اللي هو خلاص هذه الاتفاقية ملزمة
يلا، الآن احنا باقي شروط معينة إذا أتميناها، يتم نقل الملكية
من ضمنها موافقة هيئة المنافسة
هم كانوا يبون يستحوذون بشكل كامل؟
كامل إي
وأنت ليش كنتم تبون تبيعون وقتها؟
والله سؤال مهم، وقتها طالعين من أزمة كورونا
وقتها السوق ما كان واضح بالنسبة لنا
وكان في تخوف شخصي بالنسبة لي على مستوى أن القطاع ممكن ينهار
لأن كان فيه حديث كثير على سعودة توصيل الطلبات أو المناديب
في فرق بين السعودة والتوطين
السعودة نخليهم سعوديين، التوطين أحط نسب
وكان في توجه واضح من الجهات المعنية أنه سعودة
أنا عارف الوضع، أنا موصل طلبات
مستحيل السعودي، قليل، وليست مهنة تترقى فيها، وتفتح فيها بيت
مهنة مؤقتة
مع أنك رقيت المناديب اللي عندكم
إيه، بس...
قصدك ما هي...
ما تصير كبير المناديب مثلًا
قصدي ما هي حتى تكسبك مهارات
فيها مهارات، يسمونها مهارات تواصل، والأمور هذه تجي بشكل طبيعي
بس متعبة، توصل في ضغط
وروائح
وزحمة شوارع، تعب، والله العظيم
فأنا عارف الشيء هذا لأني جربت، ووصلت مئات الطلبات
فعارف المشقة، يا كم ساهر أخذت
تطلع ضايق صدرك تعبان، وعارف أن فيه خيارات بديلة أفضل
مثلًا أوبر وكريم أفضل للسعودي لأنه في سيارته
المكيف شغال، ويوصل عند العميل
خمس دقائق إذا ما نزل أو ما وصل العميل، وركب معي
العداد يبدأ يحسب عليه، مريح في سيارته
هذه لا
ولا يدور موقف ولا شيء
إيه، ويقابل عامل جنسية معينة يغلط عليك في المطعم
قد صارت لي مواقف محرجة
زائد أن سعرها قليل، لأن في نماذج الاقتصاد التشاركي
لقطاع توصيل المركبات
دخلهم الرئيسي من سعر التوصيل
فهو أوبر وكريم مصلحته أن يرفعوا سعر التوصيل
هذا دخله الأساسي
احنا لا، ليس من مصلحتنا أن نرفع سعر التوصيل
دخلك الأساسي من الطلب نفسه
فأنا نوعًا ما جالس أضغط على المندوب أصلًا
أني أوصله للسعر المُتعب بالنسبة له
بس لأن لو زدت سعر التوصيل، العميل ما راح يطلب
وإذا ما طلب العميل، أنت يا مندوب ما جاءك رزقك
فالشاهد أن كنت تبي توقف لأن كان فيه...
كان فيه كلام على السعودة
أذكر جاءت فترة تحمست بعض الجهات...
تعبت أنا بصراحة نفسيًّا
أنه شيء حسيت أنه بنيناه، وتعبنا فيه، وطحنّا فيه
ممكن يجي قرار زي كذا يقتل القطاع تمامًا
القطاع له أرقام كبيرة، ويأثر على المطاعم
راح يكون له آثار اقتصادية سيئة
كبيرة جدًّا على نمط وجودة الحياة
فجاء عرضهم، حتى أني أرسلت لهم قرار الوزارة
كانت وزارة الموارد البشرية
أرسلت لهم قرار الوزارة أن الوزارة ناوية تعيد صياغة القطاع
أو تقر تشريعات معينة، لأن جزء من مرحلة الفحص النافي للجهالة
يقول لك: إذا أنت تعرف شيء جوهري، وما تبلغني
وأكمل الصفقة، أنا ممكن أقاضيك
أخليك تدفع الفلوس كلها اللي أنا دفعتها لك، وأقدر أحتفظ بالشركة
فكنا حريصين أن أي شيء نعرفه نبلغ
حتى أرسلت لهم خطاب، وراحوا ترجموه
قلت: إذا كان في مخاطرة أنتم تأخذونها
قالوا: حسنًا، راح نأخذ المخاطرة هذه
فبدأنا معهم، ووقعنا معهم اتفاقية الشراء
وكان مشروطة بهيئة المنافسة
بدأنا نقدم أوراقنا لهيئة المنافسة
المدة هذه كلها ما أحد يدري
لأن ما صار في إعلان من طرفهم
فما أحد يدري، حتى الموظفين ما يدرون
وهو شايل هم إذا صار الخبر
كيف أنقل الخبر للموظفين، وكيف راح يتقبلونا بشكل إيجابي وللا سلبي؟
أيش البيت اللي تبي تشتريه؟
تطلع تفتح عقار
مقلق الموضوع
مقلق فعلًا
أن أنا أوعدك بمبلغ معين، وكل يوم تفتح الآلة الحاسبة
تبني عليها خطط
هذا الشيء تعلمته بصراحة لأنه أثّر علي نفسيًّا في الصفقة الأولى
خلاص أنا أبي أعطيك مبلغ معين
كنا ماشيين أمورنا تمام
قدمنا على هيئة المنافسة، قعدنا خمسة أشهر
أيش قدمتوا على هيئة المنافسة؟
اللي هو يسمونه طلب عدم ممانعة تركز اقتصادي
هيئة المنافسة، جهة حكومية هدفها أنها تحمي حق المستهلك
وتحمي القطاع بشكل عام
ما تبغى مُنشأة معينة تستحوذ على غالبية حصة السوق
إذا في حصرية على القطاع، أيش أسوي؟
أقدر أرفع الأسعار
ما يكون عندي حافز أني أبتكر وأطور
المنافسة تخدم العميل في النهاية
فالخدمة تصير سيئة، فتصير خدمة سيئة سعرها عالي
فعشان كذا الهيئة، هيئة المنافسة من أنظمتها
أو أهدافها أنها تضمن أن البيئة والمنافسة عادلة للمنشآت
وجودة عالية للمستهلكين
فقدمنا عليهم، عملية طويلة جدًّا، وإجراءات ومتطلبات كثيرة
بالنسبة لهم أيضًا كان وقتها قطاع جديد
ما فيه مرجع رئيسي للقطاع
بدأوا يبنونها بعد كورونا أو خلالها
فكانت مرحلة متعبة بصراحة
كم كانت الصفقات؟ هل تقدر تشاركها وللا؟
والله هذه من المعلومات اللي ما نقدر نشاركها لأنهم ما أفصحوا هم
بس كانت بالنسبة لنا...
أنا أقول الأرقام، واغمز
بس أتصور مبلغ راح يحسّن جودة حياتك بشكل كبير
بشكل كبير مرة، زائد أن كان عندهم حوافز كثيرة
خلنا نأخذها بطريقة ثانية
كم كان تقييم الشركة المنطقي بالنسبة لك في الفترة تلك؟
التقييم لأي شركة فعليًّا ما في شيء اسمه منطقي
بس خلنا نقول
لأن أنا يقول لك دائما: «القرد في عين أمه غزال»
إي حلو، بس بالفترة تلك
كم كنت تشوف التقييم المنطقي للشركة من إلى؟
صح، مجددًا بس عشان ما يُستَقطع المثل
فأنا فعلًا أشوف «ذا شفز» قيمته عالية مرة
أكيد يمكن شفت قيمتها 4 مليار
بس خلنا نقول بالفترة تلك كم تعتقد
تقول: لو جاءني واحد كلمني من إلى...؟
احنا كنا نأخذ على اللي يسمونها المعدل، أخذنا معدل كويس
إيه، فأنا ما أتكلم عن «دليفري هيرو»
عشان نطلع من الجانب القانوني
أنا أتكلم في تلك السنة كم كان في بالك من إلى
قيمة التقييم العادلة لو في أحد يبي يستحوذ عليك؟
تقريبًا 300 مليون في وقتها
هذه الحدود اللي تحس أن...؟
إيه، لأن مبيعاتنا في 2020
مرة أخرى، نقطة مهمة حاجز الخوف مؤثر في قرارات الإنسان
في مبيعاتنا في 2020 تقريبًا 150 مليون
فأعطونا رقم كويس، معدل كويس
زائد أنا كنت عايش الأرق هذا أن خلاص في شهر، أنا عارف الشهر
في شهر يوليو، 2021 مع السلامة
فقدّمتوا لهيئة المنافسة
أيش كان التفاصيل اللي يطلبونها منكم؟
يطلبون تفاصيل، أعطونا اتفاقية، ومبيعاتكم ومبيعاتهم
المطاعم اللي شغالة معكم ومع المنافس
اللي هو هنقرستيشن
كيف تسعرون، وكيف هم يسعرون؟
كيف يسعرون التوصيل؟
بيانات كاملة
فأتصور أخذت وقت طويل
أخذت وقت طويل
صار اللي صار، وفجأة تم الإعلان في نهاية السنة في ديسمبر
احنا وقعنا معهم في يوليو 2021
قدمنا، فقعدنا خمسة شهور، وجاء القرار الرسمي
من هيئة المنافسة أنها تمنع هذا القرار
بس قبلها ما أعطوكم شروط عشان يتم؟
إلا، يعطونكم متطلبات
أنا أذكر مثلًا أوبر وكريم حالة مشابهة
وأعطوهم شروط للتركز الاقتصادي
وتمت إي
فهل جاؤوكم قالوا: فيه شروط، وبعدين قلتوا الشروط ما تنفع؟
هو عشان خلنا نتكلم بالأشياء المفصح عنها
الأشياء المفصح عنها الإعلان اللي طلع الموجود الآن
أن بسبب ممانعة الطرفين أو أحد الطرفين
بتقديم بيانات معينة
هم عندهم أيضًا اشتراطات أني أطلب منك بيانات معينة
ما رديت علي خلال فترة زمنية معينة
أنا يحق لي أني أتخذ القرار بناءً على المعلومات المتوفرة عندي
أني أقدر أحكم على الصفقة هذه بالقبول أو بالرفض
حلو، بس كان من طبيعة الحال عندك خبر قبلما يطلع البيان؟
لا
أنت اكتشفت معنا أن...؟
إي، هم علّمونا في نفس اليوم، بعدين أعلنوا بكرة
حلو
مو كنا ندري قبلها
إيه، لأن راح يطلع الخبر
إيه، قالوا: خلاص قررنا، أيش القرار؟ الخبر راح يطلع
أيش ردة فعلك؟
والله، الحمد لله، هذه من الأشياء والدروس المستفادة
اللي تعلمتها بدروس قاسية
في حكم أنت تقرأها في كتب وترددها
وفي حكم هي اللي ترغمك أنك...
في حكم بالوجه تجي
أن لا تبني آمال كثيرة على المستقبل، ولا ترسم أشياء كثيرة للمستقبل
أحسك وقتها كنت تعتقد أنك تسوق أو تقود مركب راح يغرق
كأنك كنت تشوف أنك خلاص أنا...
كلا الحالتين
أخطأت مرتين أنا
الخطأ الأول أني كنت أعتقد أن متجهين نحو الهاوية، واتخذت قرار
الخطأ الثاني تعلقت في الصفقة هذه على المستوى الشخصي
فلما جاء الرفض كان صادم بالنسبة لي، لأني أيضًا بنيت آمال
رحت حذفت «الأكسل» ذاك اللي كنت تحسب فيه
إي، فدائمًا المشكلة، التوقعات عن الواقع إذا اختلفت
تسبب للإنسان اضطرابات نفسية
فهذه من الدروس اللي تعلمتها أن ما تعرف
هل تعتقد كمنافس استفادوا الآن من أنهم شافوا بياناتكم وتفاصيلكم؟
أكيد أنهم استفادوا
أكيد تعطيهم فرصة اطلاع على بيانات ما يقدرون يطلعون عليها
بس مو هذا مربط الفرس، ما هي على البيانات
ولا كان كل واحد قام يهكر بيانات الثاني
هي على الفريق، وعلى الثقافة، وعلى التوجه الاستراتيجي
فاحنا أتذكر حطيت تغريدة وكتبت كذا حطيت الخبر، وكتبت والقادم أفضل
فعلًا كنت أحاول أقنع نفسي
أن «وَعَسَى أَنْ تَكْرَهُوا شَيْئًا وَهُوَ خَيْرٌ لَكُمْ وَعَسَى أَنْ تُحِبُّوا شَيْئًا وَهُوَ شَرٌّ لَكُمْ»
حلو، فمتى انتهى موضوع الاستحواذ؟
انتهى في ديسمبر نهاية 2021
«جاهز» متى كلّموكم؟
بعدها، طلع الخبر في الصحف العالمية
طلع في «بلومبورق»
من ديسمبر حتى مارس، خلال أربع شهور من بداية سنة 2022
تواصلوا معنا أكثر من جهة منافسين خارجيين وعالميين
صناديق خاصة اللي يسمونها (private equities)
صناديق استثمار جريء، إلى آخره
زنتوا في عيونهم الحين
إيه، يوم طلع الخبر، «ديليفري هيرو»...
ففعلًا «وَعَسَى أَنْ تَكْرَهُوا شَيْئًا وَهُوَ خَيْرٌ لَكُمْ»
ففادنا هذا الشيء بطريقة غير مباشرة
فجتنا عروض كويسة، وأعلى من العرض اللي جاءنا بضعفين أو ثلاث ضعاف
اللي كنا موقعينه مع «دليفري هيرو»
فجاءتنا عروض كثيرة
بعدين جاءنا عرض «جاهز» في شهر مارس أيضًا سنة 2022
سبحان الله، نفس التوقيت، هؤلاء شهر مارس...
فجاءنا عرض «جاهز» وكان في يدنا عروض ثانية
وكان عندنا عروض ثانية أعلى من عرض «جاهز»
عرض جاهز اللي هو كان 650 مليون، زائد 100 مليون للمؤسسين
في البداية ما كنت متقبل الرقم
ليش في عرض للاستحواذ على الشركة، ومبلغ زائد للمؤسسين؟
في البداية الرقم شخصيًّا ما كان مناسب لي
الشركاء كانوا متقبلين الرقم
شوف المستثمرين الماليين يحط معك مبلغ، خلينا نقول يحط مليون ريال
وصل مرحلة أنه حقق عائد مثلًا عشرة مليون يقتنع بها
ما يطمح أن يقول: لا، إلغي أبي أكمل إلى 100 مليون
هو بالنسبة له حقق عائد مرة كويس
فكل اللي دخلوا معنا حققوا عوائد مقارنة في السوق عشرة أضعاف
عشرة أضعاف
بعضهم ستين ضعف
فبالنسبة لهم أنه عرض كويس
أنا فكرت فيه من ناحية أن يصير فيه يسمونها توحد القوات
احنا ومع «ذا شفز» احنا و«جاهز» بدل ما ننافسهم، نتحد مع بعض
ففي مصلحة لنا ولهم، ومصلحة للقطاع، ومصلحة للمستهلك كذلك
أنا أخذتها من هذا الجانب، حسّنوا العرض
أن 100 مليون إضافية للمؤسسين اللي هم أنا و«وعبدالرحمن المرشد»
مقابل مستهدفات معينة
وقلنا: حسنًا، استخرنا، كان عندنا عرض ثاني، اعتذرنا منه
وقلنا: نتوكل على الله، نحط يد بيد، ونشتغل مع بعض
فأرسلوا لنا الاتفاق الغير ملزم في شهر مايو
نفس الإجراءات
إيه، بعدين يبدأون يسوون الفحص النافي للجهالة، يعينون مستشارين
احنا عيننا مستشارين قانونيين، وشركات عالمية
فعليها تكلفة علينا احنا
يعني مو أنا يعطيني ورقة أوقع، لا
عشان يعرف المشاهد الصفقات هذه عادةً
اتفاقية الشراء تتكون من 150 لـ 200 صفحة
جمل معقدة قانونيًّا، ونضطر أن نتعاقد مع مكاتب أجنبية
ساعتها بـ1000 دولار مثلًا، على سبيل المثال، تكلفة كبيرة علينا
وأجيب أيضًا مستشار مالي كذلك
فهم أيضًا يعينون مستشارين، نفس الإجراءات
تأخرنا عشان ننجز اتفاقية الاستحواذ
قعدت معنا تقريبًا، احنا جلسنا معهم في شهر مايو
أو الاتفاق المبدئي اللي هو الخطوط العريضة
وقعنا واتفقنا في نهاية شهر نوفمبر، يعني ستة أشهر، فطوّلنا شوي
الصفقة اللي قبل قعدنا ثلاثة أشهر، هنا قعدنا ستة أشهر
فاحنا دخلنا الصفقة هذه بناءً على الانطباع اللي قبل
بناءً على انطباع «دليفري هيرو» أن الجدول الزمني هذا هو
بس خبرة «دليفري هيرو» لا تقارن بخبرة «جاهز» عندهم خبرة عالمية
أيضًا هذه من الانطباعات
هذه المشكلة أن الإنسان دائمًا يحط انطباعات مخالفة للواقع
فكان أيضًا في وعود أن الموضوع راح يكون سريع جدًّا
وقعنا، الحمد لله، في شهر نوفمير
والاختلاف أن هنا شركة «جاهز» مطروحة في سوق المال
فمجبورين أنهم يعلنون عن حدث جوهري
فمن بداية السنة والناس عارفة
ناس كثير كانوا يعتقدون أن الصفقة تمت
فأيضًا تعيش تحت ضغط ثاني
يباركون لك
اللي يبارك لك
ووقعنا الحمدلله في شهر نوفمبر
الآن نفس الاشتراطات لازم أنت تقدم على هيئة المنافسة وهيئة سوق المال
هيئة سوق المال ليش؟
لأن جزء من الصفقة أسهم
كم كان جزء من الصفقة؟
خمسين - خمسين، فهم عشان يصدرون أسهم
لازم يعقدون الجمعية العمومية الغير عايدية، هذا مسماها
وعشان يعقدونها لازم أيضًا يقدمون أوراق لهيئة سوق المال
ويأخذون موافقتها
فأنت لازم تقدم أوراق معينة، قوائم مالية مدققة
تأخذ المنافسة، وتنتظر واحد وعشرين يوم
بعدين تُعقَد الجمعية بعدين توافق الجمعية بعدين تتم الصفقة
مشروط أيضًا بهيئة المنافسة، فاحنا قدمنا على هيئة المنافسة
للأسف أيضًا تأخر الوضع أكثر من الصفقة السابقة
الصفقة السابقة كنا
في هيئة المنافسة أصلًا أغلب الصفقات يتمون خلال ثلاثة شهور
فـ«ديليفري هيرو» قعدنا خمسة أشهر
مع «جاهز» احنا قدمنا بداية ديسمبر
ما تم الإعلان إلا سبتمبر الماضي، فعشرة أشهر إلى أن صدرت
أذكر حتى يوم سجلنا حلقة «جاهز»
كان لسه ما كان واضح الموضوع أنه تمت الصفقة، وللا لا
فتأخر الموضوع مرة
في شيء مهم في الصفقة اللي يسمونه تاريخ انتهاء الصفقة
أنا أوقع أنا وإيّاك على الصفقة، ونحط شروط
ونقول لك: لازم ننجز الشروط قبل التاريخ هذا
إذا جاء التاريخ هذا ولا أنجزنا، تُعتَبَر الصفقة لاغية
ما لم يتفق الطرفان على تجديد مهلة إضافية
وليش طوّل موضوع مع هيئة المنافسة؟
فاحنا أول شيء كانت...
احنا وقعنا في نوفمبر، كانت الاتفاقية ستنتهي في أبريل السنة الحالية
طال الموضوع مع هيئة المنافسة
أيش اللي خلاها تصير أطول من موضوع «دليفري هيرو» عند هيئة المنافسة؟
والله ما أقدر، الموضوع مو عندنا، وليس من صالحنا احنا أن نتأخر
تعرف أنا أبي أعطيك، أوعدك بمبلغ معين
تمام؟ أنت من مصلحتك أني أتأخر عليك، ولا أبكر عليك؟
إيه، لا، فاهم عليك
ما كان عندنا مصلحة، كنا حريصين أن نخلص بسرعة
حلو
فجاء شهر أربعة انتهت الاتفاقية
وما قدرنا نأخذ موافقة هيئة المنافسة وهيئة سوق المال
فاضطرينا أن نمدد ثلاثة شهور إضافية على أمل
ومددنا لنهاية شهر يوليو، وما طلعت موافقة هيئة المنافسة
فقلنا...، كل فترة التمديد يصير في نقاش داخلي
نمدد وللا ما نمدد؟
لأن التجربة متعبة، وكانت متعبة يمكن بالنسبة لي
مع الصفقة هذه تشتغل مع أكثر من مستشار ماخذة جُل وقتك وتركيزك
أثرت علي بصراحة نفسيًّا، وحتى جسديًّا
الرواية الدارجة، وهذه قبل فترة قريبة جدًّا
أن اتفقتوا، وكل شيء تمام
بس بعدما طرحوا «جاهز» نزل السهم
واختلفت الآن أو اختلت قيمة الصفقة
وصارت أقل مما أنتم موعودين فيه
لا
هذا اللي مقتنعين فيه الناس
لا، غير صحيح لأن احنا مددنا كذا مرة
مددنا، والسهم أيضًا كان في نزول
فمددنا بنهاية أبريل، وكان السهم نازل
هل أنت قاعد تقول لي في جميع اللحظات
اللي صارت فيها الموضوع هذا أو في جميع الأوقات
ما كان سعر السهم مشكلة بالنسبة لكم؟
لا، ما كان، لأننا نعتقد أن إذا تمت الصفقة
أنا وجهة نظري، إذا تمت الصفقة راح يصير في عائد على السهم
حلو، الناس يجزمون أنه هذا هو السبب
اللي كل شوية ترجعون إلى طاولة المفاوضات
لا، احنا كان هدفنا أن نبي نخلص
الإنسان له طاقة
تعيش نفس التجربة مرتين
تلهيك عن أشياء كثيرة حتى تأثر على النمو
بس، الحمد لله، ضاعفنا في سنة 2021 وسنة 2022
بس أنها أعاقتنا بصراحة، تركيز كامل
أيش اللي صار أجل؟
أقول لك: مدّدنا الحين شهر أبريل إلى شهر يوليو
على أمل تطلع موافقة هيئة المنافسة، طلعت في شهر سبتمبر
باقي هيئة سوق المال
الإجراء كان، خلنا نقول بالمختصر مددنا إلى أكتوبر
وجاء أكتوبر حسينا أن الصفقة تحتاج أيضًا ممكن خمسة شهور إضافية
خمسة شهور إلى ستة شهور إضافية
الفترة هذه قلنا: خلاص اتفقنا أن ما نمدد
وتم الإعلان أن أُلغيت الصفقة بسبب عدم التمديد إلى فترة إضافية
أحس ما أشبعني الجواب
هل أقدر أعرف على الأقل إذا يسمح لك الموضوع
الموضوع من عندك وللا من عند «جاهز»
مين اللي كان يبغى يلغي؟
ما أحد كان يبغى يلغي، ما أعتقد أنه...
أقصد في هذه المرحلة، يوم طوّل الموضوع
أنا ما أعتقد أن «جاهز» جاءت ودخلوا وصرفوا
واطلعوا على بياناتنا، وجلسنا معهم، وهدفهم إلغاء بالنهاية
أكيد، بس قصدي يوم وصلتوا للنهاية
أن جددنا أكثر من مرة، فاحنا شفنا أن الموضوع راح يطول
الريال اللي أنا أتفق أنا وإياك عليه في سنة معينة
يختلف قيمته عن الآن
احنا قررنا كشركاء الغالبية أن ما راح نمدد، ونشوف خيارات ثانية
فالقرار من عندكم أن ارتفعت قيمة «ذا شفز»
فتشوفون الأفضل أن ما تطولون موضوع المفاوضات إلى أطول من كذا؟
لأن شفنا أنه لو مددنا ما رح نخلص، تكلفة علينا وعليهم
حسافة ما تمت، فهي ما لها دخل في قيمة السهم؟
لا، بالعكس احنا حتى حاولنا
مرة أخرى، أنا كنت مؤمن أن في مصلحة القطاع
وناس كثير تفاءلوا في الموضوع
مصلحة القطاع يعني بدل ما أنا أنافس
تكلفته حتى بعدين بكرة تكلفة الاستحواذ، إذا كثروا اللاعبين ترتفع
تكلفة الاستحواذ على مين؟
كل واحد يحاول يسحب
كلنا راح نعلن مثلًا سناب شات
إذا ما فيه إلا أنا راح أعلن تفرق إذا أنت جالس تعلن معي
لأنها هي من اللي يدفع أكثر؟
فهذا محور بسيط، ومن مصلحة العميل أيضًا
الحمد لله، تم الإعلان أنه ألغيت الصفقة
مرة ثانية، نفس السيناريو اللي كان قبل
أن متأكدين القادم أفضل
«وَعَسَى أَنْ تَكْرَهُوا شَيْئًا وَهُوَ خَيْرٌ لَكُمْ»
وأحذف صفحة الإكسل، وللا ما سويتها هذه المرة؟
حاذفها من قبل من بدايتها، إيه
هذه المرة ما عشّمت نفسك
فالحمد لله، حتى والله تفاجأت من أثرها
أن الموظفين زادت إنتاجيتهم، استانسوا
القطاع نفسه صار فيه تفاعل إيجابي
الموظفين عندهم أسهم؟
لا، بس فيه بعضهم
فتحمسوا أكثر أن يمكن يطلع لهم شيء؟
لا، الكل، احنا كنا واعدينهم
بشكل عام، قلنا: خلاص, احنا نعتقد أنه «ذا شفز» عنده فرص أكبر
والحمد لله، مثلما قلت لك: مع العوائق اللي صارت
ضاعفنا أرقام 2021 عن 2020
وضاعفنا أرقام 2022 عن 2021، والسنة هذه أيضًا
ودّي أحفّر أكثر في الموضوع هذا
لأن أنا متأكد حتى في ناس كثير راح يتواصلون معي
يقولون: ليش ما سألت كذا، وليش ما سألت كذا؟
في معلومات كثير ما تقدر أنت...
بالضبط، أنا أبي أحترم بس أن الجانب القانوني، وبرضو علاقتنا مع «جاهز»
إلا إذا تبي تجيبني وتجيب «أبو عبدالله، حمد البكر» عادي
مع بعض جالسين هنا
مع بعض، ما عندي مشكلة
«الاتجاه المعاكس»
لا، أنا أبي أحترم صراحة موضوع الاتفاق اللي بينكم
أنكم كلكم موقعين على عدم الإفصاح
وبالإضافة برضو أنا أحترم «أبو عبدالله» وأحترمك
فما ودي يصير الموضوع إثارة للجدل
أكثر مما هو توضيح أن يا جماعة ما له علاقة في سعر السهم
الموضوع طوّل أكثر من اللازم، وشفنا أنه خلاص
الآن ما عاد في توافق
أول شيء أنه أرهقكم الموضوع بشكل كبير
جدًّا
وشفت أن فيه فرصة أفضل مستقبلًا مع ارتفاع قيمة الشركة
هذا اللي فهمته، هل هذا فهمي صحيح؟
صحيح
حلو، كلّمك أحد بعدها قال: نبي نستحوذ عليكم وللا؟
والله ما نقدر، متى هذا، أي جزء هذا؟
ما أنتم شركة مدرجة يا أخي
هذا أي جزء؟
إيه، بس ما في أحد كلّمك، قال:...؟
والله، الحمد لله
مليون بالـ100 في أحد، أخذها مني
في، وفي خيارات كثيرة بس نفس الـ... ما راح...
خيارات كثيرة بصراحة متنوعة يمكن أكثر من اللي قبل
ما راح نستعجل
راح نركز أكثر في النمو
نركز في سنة 2024 أنها تكون سنة استثنائية بالنسبة لنا
ونشوف، ما تدري فعلًا الواحد يمشي على كف القدر
ما يدري أيش المكتوب
فما تدري فعلًا، احنا من البداية ما كنا ندري، من بداية 2016
فيه ناس سألوني يقولوا: كنت تدري أنك راح تبيع
وشركة، الحمد لله، الآن عدد الموظفين يتجاوز 500 موظف
عدد المطاعم اللي شغالين معك أكثر من 12 ألف
90% من الموظفين السعوديين
نحقق أثر قوي في المجتمع
مساهمات كثيرة نسويها في المجتمع
كل يوم أجي المكتب أشوف الشباب متحمسين
يعطيني طابع أكثر أو يعطيني حافز أكثر أني أكمل
وهو وقود، وقودي أنا الشخصي
وأتوقع ما فيك حيل الحين أصلًا تدخل في صفقة جديدة في الاستحواذ
لا، أنا صرت خبير، عارف أيش النقاط اللي ممكن تسبب...
لأن حتى بالنسبة لي، لو أنظر لها بأثر رجعي
هذه دورة مكثفة، أخذتها في «الإم إن أيه» في الاستحواذ
مريت بتفاصيل كثيرة، فالحمد لله، مركزين على النمو
ومركزين أكثر أن في رهان أكثر على الاقتصاد
أنت جالس تشوف، ما شاء الله، الاقتصاد السعودي جالس ينمو
قطاع التوصيل بشكل عام راح ينمو
النمو مركب تقريبًا 13%
نشوف الأخبار الحلوة اللي جالسين نسمعها
استضافة السعودية لكأس العالم، إن شاء الله، والإكسبو
الحمد لله، محظوظين في هذا الوقت
ما شاء الله، كل الخدمات وخمسين موظف؟
500 موظف
500 إي ما أدري أيش فيني
كثيرين، ما شاء الله
احنا عندنا فريق المتاجر السحابية 100 موظف مع الورود
احنا عندنا علامات تجارية نسويها
وأنتم الظاهر اللي قدمتوا خدمات استشارية
أو سويتوا خدمات استشارية تقدمونها للشركات؟
تسويقية، إي احنا نقدم خدمات
من الأشياء المميزات اللي احنا نحرص أن العلاقة لازم تكون ربحية لكل الأطراف
فاحنا دائمًا نؤمن أن نجاح المطاعم من نجاحنا
وين رايحين على كذا، هل راح تتوسعون وتطلعون؟
وتحققون اللي تكلمتوا فيه من قبل مع «دليفري هيرو»
اللي هو موضوع تطبيق النموذج في دول الخليج؟
احنا نعتقد أن ما راح نطلع في أي سوق
بنموذج التوصيل الوحيد فقط اللي هو التوصيل
ما في أي قيمة مضافة ممكن تحققها في أي سوق خارج السعودية
بل أنت راح تدخل عبء إضافي على السوق
وتزيد من تكاليف...
بس أنها مزدحمة الأسواق؟
مزدحمة
ما لم تحقق تجربة جديدة أو مجموعة من القيم والخدمات
اللي أنت تقدر تفرض نفسك على العميل وعلى التاجر كذلك
أنت لازم تأخذ، ترى قطاعنا مو فقط تبيع للعميل
أنا أبيع أيضًا للتاجر
أنا لازم أكسب التاجر في صفي
عشان كذا هذا الشيء احنا مركزين فيه في «ذا شفز»
من الأشياء اللي أطلقناها اللي هي خدمة شارك وحقق
اللي هو الآن أنت كمتجر
احنا نأخذ منك نسبة 15%
احنا نقدر نأخذ منك نسبة 5% فقط
نعطيك رابط تحطه في خرائط قوقل أو في إنستقرام
تحطه في أي إعلان لك
أي عميل يدخل من هذا الرابط راح يفتح على «ذا شفز»
احنا فقط راح ندفعك 5%
حلوة الحركة، على أساس تقول: هذا عميلك مو عميلي
ونعطيك البيانات، تشوف العميل
مو في المطاعم كانت فترة زعلانة
أيضًا نعطيك بيانات العملاء، تشوف أرقامهم، وكل شيء عندك
فمن الخدمات اللي أيضًا يقدمها للمطاعم
اللي هي مثلما ذكرت استشارية أو الخدمات التسويقية
أن تعال يا مطعم تبغى تدخل السوق؟
احنا نسوي لك خطة تسويقية كاملة
احنا نتشارك مع الـ...
احنا نصرف بشكل كبير في المؤثرين
في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
أنت مطعم تبي تعلن مع المؤثرين، احنا ندفع 50% لـ 50%
فالخدمات الاستشارية كلها تدور حول تسويق التجار
تسويق التجار إي
وتحاسبونهم نقد، وللا ترفعون النسبة، وللا شلون؟
لا، أنت يا متجر، احنا نسوي...
لما نعلن مع مؤثرين ندرس كل مؤثر، ونجرب على أي متجر
نجربه على أكثر من تصنيف إلى أن نعرف هذا كويس معنا وللا لا؟
فبنينا قاعدة ذهبية من المؤثرين، نعرف أداءهم
والعائد اللي يحققونه من الإعلانات
فأنت مثلًا متجر تبي تعلن؟ تتواصل معنا أو مع مدير الحساب
يقول لك: تعال هذه قائمة المؤثرين
ترى سعره كذا، واحنا نجيب سعر مرة كويس
تدفع فقط النص، وما راح تدفعه نقدًا
راح نخصمه من المبيعات في نهاية الشهر؟
حتى في التدفق النقدي ما يأثر على المطعم
أتصور ما تقدرون تخدمون فيها كل العملاء
لأن في النهاية، عدد الفريق محدود
وهو اللي راح يشتغل على الموضوع هذا
صحيح
فائدتها أنتم شفتوها في أنكم تكبرون العلامات التجارية الجديدة؟
أن نكون في صف العميل
هذا كلام حلو بس...
لا، كلام فعلًا
الكلام العملي الحين
صف العميل، لما أقول العميل دائمًا اللي هو المطعم والمستخدم النهائي
بس أيش جالس تستفيد فعليًّا؟
شوف قاعدة أساسية في التجارة
ما راح تحقق أي قيمة إلا إذا خلقت قيمة
أنا لازم أخلق قيمة للمطعم
أنا لازم دوري أني أزيد مبيعاته
إذا زادت مبيعاته...
بس هذه نهايتها ما حصرية عليك
يعني إذا صار المطعم معروف
في النهاية برضو أيضًا راح يحقق مبيعات من منصات ثانية
قصدي ما هي ميزة مرتبطة في «ذا شفز»
إيه، بس أنا هذه ميزة احنا نعتقد أن واجب علينا تقديمها للمطعم
المطعم أنا لازم أساعد في التسويق
أنت لازم ترتفع مبيعاتك
إذا ارتفعت مبيعاتك أنا راح أستفيد بعد
أنا ما أبغى مطاعم، أيش الفائد أنت تسوي نظام توصيل
والمطاعم تنخفض مبيعاتها، وما تبيع؟
ما استفدت شيء
فأنت مكمل للمطاعم، وجودة التطبيقات مكمل لدور أساسي
اللي هم المطاعم
وقطاع المطاعم قطاع أساسي في قطاع السعودية
وأكثر قطاع يصرف فيه العميل
62% من صرفية العميل السعودي على قطاع المطاعم
وأكثر قطاع يصرف فيه
ويعتبر من العناصر المهمة من رؤية 2030، ومن جودة الحياة
فهذا القطاع لازم أنه يُهتَم فيه
لازم أن جميع المكملين واللاعبين في القطاع هذا
تكون في علاقة تشاركية ناجحة
حلو، بس أنت ما قلت لنا عن موضوع توسع الخليج
لأن أتصور حتى أن عندكم إعلانات كثير من موسم الرياض
لناس من برة
ففي أسواق خليجية يمكن أن تتوسعون لها بخدمات مختلفة؟
صحيح، نفس الفكرة، احنا عندنا خطة أن نتوسع
بس ننتظر أن القيمة تكتمل
أو مجموعة القيم تكتمل للمطعم وللعميل
واحنا مثلما ذكرت لك، احنا بنينا «ذا شفز»
أن تخيلنا عميل معين حطيناه في النص
وهذا العميل، أيش يحتاج؟
يحتاج توصيل، سوينا توصيل
يحتاج هدايا، يبغى يهدي برقر
يبغى يهدي ورد، يبغى يحجز، يبغى... كل شيء
فالعميل سلوكه متغير فاحنا راح نكون متغيرين معه
بس لو نبي نأخذها بشكل أوضح
التوسع راح يكون بشيء غير التوصيل؟
راح يكون ممكن بأنظمة أو بشيء مو بالتوصيل
لأن أنت التوصيل تقول: مزدحم؟
إيه، احنا لازم نطور في نظام التوصيل
أنت لازم أنك تحرص كيف التوصيل يوصل العميل
تقلل الأخطاء اللي تصير
لأن الأخطاء اللي تصير هذه مكلفة على المطعم والعميل والتطبيق
لأن لما تطلب وجبة معينة تجيك عكس أو أنها ناقصة شيء
تضر العميل، وتضر المطعم، وتضر التطبيق
حلو، أيش جديدكم اللي راح يجي للسوق السعودي؟
هل في مزايا جديدة جاية، أو شيء؟
أعطينا كذا حصرية
إيه، والله شوف احنا...
علمًا أن الحلقة راح تطلع الأسبوع الجاي، إن شاء الله
من وقت التصوير، فراعي الشيء هذا
متى؟
مو الأحد هذا، الأحد اللي بعده
فعلّمنا شيء راح يطلع الفترة الجاية
والله شوف احنا حريصين...
بصراحة تعرف أيضًا عندنا نموذج نقاط الولاء
أنك كلما تطلب تحقق نقاط
احنا نعتقد أن هذه عملتنا في المستقبل
فراح نبني عليها خدمات إضافية
أنا سمعت خدمات اجتماعية، طراطيش حكي يعني
مرة ثانية، أنت لازم حركة أو دائرة التطوير عندك مستمرة
ففي أشياء جديدة، هدفنا أن...
كلمة مجددًا قلتها عشرين مرة
فهدفنا دائمًا أن نكون مبتكرين وفي صف العميل وفي صف المطعم
كلام جميل، بس هذه النقطة تحديدًا
أنا ما ودي أقولها بعدين في ناس يروح يقلدون، اصبر شوي
أخاف الفريق التقني يقول لي: اصبر، لأن أنا وإياهم ترى...
لا تأكد لي ولا شيء، بس اللي أنا تخيّلته
هو شيء امتداد للتقييمات والتعليقات والأشياء الموجودة عندكم
صحيح
يلا وصلنا
بس يلا ما تكلمنا عن تصميمك ما دامك...
خلّيها مفاجأة أحلى
الواجهة الجديدة مميزة، أنت جربتها؟
حُرِقَت المفاجأة خلاص
كان ودي لو طالعين قبل
لا، مو مشكلة، الله يعطيك العافية أبو راكان
جدًّا سعدت اليوم باستضافتك اللي أخيرًا قدرنا نرتبها
ونتطلع، إن شاء الله، لاستحواذ يتم لـ«ذا شفز»
وينقلك لمرحلة جديدة
مو شرط
ليش؟
مو شرط استحواذ
تبي فلوس، وللا ما تبي فلوس؟
أكيد، أنا ماني مشروع خيري
بس في فرص كثيرة غير الاستحواذ ممكن
في مخططين؟
إن شاء الله
مُبهَم مرة
عسى الله...، شوف أنا أخذتها قاعدة في الحياة، ما تدري
أنت ما تبي تعشّم نفسك بولا شيء
ما تدري، حتى أنا قاعد أقول لا تتعب
امشي إلى أن إذا صار الشيء اعلن
الله يرزقك ويرزقنا وجميع من يستمع
الله يعطيك العافية، وشكرًا لك على وقتك
الله يعافيك، شكرًا لك، الله يعطيكم العافية
شكرًا لكم وشكرًا لعبد الملك آل سعيد في إنتاج المحتوى
في التحرير: عدي عيسى
في التصوير: ياسر بن غانم
في الإضاءة: ياسر كدشة
في التسجيل: يوسف إبراهيم
في الهندسة الصوتية: عبدالعزيز المزي
في الإخراج الإبداعي: وهاب موسى
في الإخراج الفني: مجد الملي ومساعده وسيم معين
وفي الإنتاج التنفيذي: غيداء التميمي
هذا بودكاست سوالف بزنس، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع